hello everyone I'm here to talk to you
about a vision of artificial
intelligence that goes beyond machines
and algorithms a vision which Embraces
humans and nature as integral parts of a
cyber physical ecosystem of intelligence
a vision that is based on first
principles derived from physics and
biology
Professor Carl friston just dropped a
paper called designing ecosystems of
intelligence from first principles
now one of the principles is active
inference a formulation of adaptive
Behavior which can be read as a physics
of intelligence
active inference says that intelligent
systems are those which can accumulate
evidence for a generative model of their
sensed World in other words they can
learn from their observations and update
their beliefs accordingly
they can also act on their environment
to reduce uncertainty and achieve their
goals but active inference is not about
individual agents it also explains how
ensembles of Agents can share beliefs
and cooperate through communication
protocols
this leads to a formal account of
collective intelligence that rests on
shared narratives and goals
so how do we realize this Vision friston
proposes a research agenda for the next
decade and Beyond which aims to design
such ecosystems of intelligence from
scratch
they suggest developing a shared
hyperspatial modeling language and
transaction protocols as well as novel
methods for measuring and optimizing
collective intelligence
so why should we care about this Vision
it's because it offers a way to harness
the power of artificial intelligence for
the common good without compromising
human dignity or autonomy and because it
challenges us to rethink our
relationship with technology nature and
each other and because it invites us to
join in a global community of sense
makers who are curious about the world
and eager to improve it
enjoy the show
our shared human journey is filled with
examples of simple ideas that were
nonetheless hard to discover and some
that even once explained remain hard to
comprehend
their subtle Simplicity belies their
far-reaching and deep consequences
examples might include the principle of
relativity
quantum mechanics
the principle of parsimony and entropy
I think the free energy principle is
another example
profound and far-reaching yet belied by
its simplicity
it has on the one hand been dismissed as
a triviality or even tautology
and on the other hailed as revolutionary
and everything in between
it has the potential to reshape how we
view the connection between inanimate
matter and the living things
and even to answer the question of how
and why Consciousness and intelligence
might emerge from physical matter and
processes
that means a world where all things from
particles to people to the largest
systems
all move or evolve according to two
processes
which combine
the first is a smooth flowing Evolution
think of planets orbiting a star or
waves Rippling over water or through
Quantum fields
the second is a random process that
knocks around the smooth flow in
unpredictable ways
think of twinkling stars or audio static
you might think of these two processes
as a kind of Order and Chaos or yin and
yay
forever intertwined and enmeshed
these two very different effects combine
into a chaotic flow which may be
entangled in a kind of tropical storm
while still maintaining a semblance of
structure and things
think about raindrops undulating down to
earth in a state of constant flux
yet still droplets
or a human being growing and adapting to
the surprises of Life all the while
remaining an individual physical entity
biology often asks the question what
must things do in order to exist
Professor friston has turned that
question on its head and developed
perhaps the ultimate existential
formalism
he asks if things exist
what must they do
from the foundation of stochastic
differential equations friston
demonstrates that things which are
defined by a Markov blanket must always
move towards a pullback attractor
a special set of attracting states which
maintains the Integrity of the Markov
blanket and therefore a things coherence
and identity over time
one of the profound consequences of this
is that the Dynamics of such a system
its laws of motion
will manifest a form of flow Dynamics
which can be interpreted as Bayesian
active inference
in other words such a thing maintains an
internal equivalent of a generative
model encoding beliefs about the world
and itself
the thing uses the model to decide
actions and then performs a Bayesian
update based on the outcomes
for me the idea that inference something
widely perceived as purely abstract or
mathematical
the idea that it can be driven by simple
Laws of Motion dynamically maintaining
the boundaries between things
maintaining order in the face of Chaos
is frankly astonishing
what's more the free energy principle is
so General that it applies that all
scales of size and time
leading to an ecosystem of things
interacting across scales
perhaps in that multi-scale active
inference we might finally find the keys
to a mathematics of emergence and
consciousness
this episode is sponsored by enumerite
um I'm extremely grateful to them for
sponsoring machine learning Street talk
I mean remember I do everything myself
on this channel it's a lot of time it's
a lot of hard work it's very expensive I
pay for other software licenses and all
of the equipment so
um yeah having that support from numerai
means a lot to me and it means that I
can keep doing what I'm doing basically
so thank you to numerai so a little bit
about numerai they are a data science
competition platform to predict the
stock market they've already paid out
over 50 million uh dollars for 5 000
models on their platform and they say
that it's the highest paying data
science platform in the world
now you can get started really easily
for free and they've got a couple of
examples on their GitHub repo actually
using xgboost
um and the data comes in parquet format
so you can get up and running really
easily you can submit your predictions
weekly or daily you can do it either
manually or you can do it automatically
and they provide many many years of of
back testing data as well so you can
fine tune and test your models and do a
bunch of statistical Diagnostics you can
work your way up the leaderboard for
bragging rights and stake your model
with their NMR cryptocurrency to earn
rewards now staking is a vote of
confidence of your model and the reason
they do that is to prevent overfitting
and to reduce the
um you know bad models from kind of
contributing bad intelligence to their
to their aggregate now a well-performing
model is rewarded in proportion to its
stake but a poorly performing model is
punished by burning a portion of these
stake now numeri have a huge community
of data scientists of all levels
swapping ideas and advice and they have
some Community forums as well which you
should join now um just a personal note
from me this is a form of betting on the
predicted performance of your models
which can go up or down remember the
data is abstracted from the actual
performance of the stocks they they
don't correlate to actual stock
performance so there are folks on the
platform who have made lots of money but
there's also folks who have lost money
as well so please be responsible and
only stake what you can afford to lose
and have confidence in try to have fun
use it as a place to sharpen up your
data science skills and to be the best
version of yourself and use all of the
latest models that we've been talking
about here on on Street Talk but um yeah
anyway thank you again to numerai for
sponsoring us Professor frisson it's an
absolute honor to meet you well thank
you very much for having me
um so we've had you on the show two
times now
and in the first show we went into
um Exquisite detail about the free
energy principle and active inference
so um you're extremely famous for
introducing this existential imperative
which is to say if things survive what
must they do
they gain information about the world
around them in a cybernetic Loop we find
a model which fits well while
maintaining High entropy if you have a
higher entropy model you have greater
flexibility to adapt to new information
it's an absolutely beautiful idea so um
welcome thank you nicely articulated I
was speaking with Keith yesterday and he
said out of all of the guests that we've
had on mlst you are by far his favorite
and he says he looks up to you very much
so he's he's very gutted that he
couldn't come today to be part of this
it's very gracious of it
so um you just wrote a paper and it's
called a designing ecosystems of
intelligence from first principles
you led with this white paper lays out a
vision of research and development in
the field of artificial intelligence for
the next decade and Beyond its
denouement I wasn't sure if I was going
to say that way is a cyber physical
ecosystem of natural and synthetic sense
making in which humans are integral
participants what we call shared
intelligence this vision is premised on
active inference the formulation of
adaptive behavior that can be read as
the physics of intelligence and which
inherits from the physics of
self-organization
so um you went on and by the way there's
an interesting link with Michael Levin's
work here so we had him on the show
recently and maybe even transhumanism as
well we could we can get into that
um but you went on you said in this
context we understand intelligence as
the capacity to accumulate evidence for
a generative model of one's sensed World
also known as self-evidencing over
multiple scales and crucially you said
active inference foregrounds and
existential imperative of intelligent
systems namely curiosity or the
resolution of uncertainty and the same
imperative underwrites belief sharing in
ensembles of agents in which certain
aspects which is to say factors of each
agent's generative model provide common
ground or a frame of reference
so can you sketch some of this out for
me
yes you've used all my favorite words
though I presume that I actually used
all the wear fat to be truthful
um Maxwell ramstead was with one of the
key architect of this so this was a um
this white paper was a response to a
brief just to think seriously and
pragmatically how this sort of high
Church theoretical approach to you know
intelligence and self-organization would
play out in industry in the way that we
actually use
um technology
um over the next decade and that white
paper is the product of our massive
Asians and discussions
um but just drilling down on on the sort
of basic message there
um the emphasis was as you say on
um what it is to exist and how that
would manifest in terms of
intelligent behavior
um and to a certain extent certainly I
and I think a number of the other
co-authors were reading intelligence as
the kind of inference that you would
need to do in order to maintain your
existence so hence the existential
imperative I have to say that's a
slightly
um
poetic interpretation of free energy
principle which is the other way around
of course that if you exist it looks as
if you are behaving intelligently if you
read intelligence as the right kind of
belief updating that enables you to
maintain yourself in some characteristic
state so that's that's essentially
um what that existential imperative was
all about you just a one way of reading
the physics the mechanics of systems
that are open in open exchange with the
rest of their world or their Eco Niche
um simply in virtue of the fact that
they are around for an extended periods
of period of time and have this
characteristic set of states that they
occupy that defines them as the kind of
thing that they are I think the move
really that was
inspired by this remit to look okay well
that's very nice you can write lots of
papers about that and have a nice chats
with your friends and colleagues about
it but how does that actually work in
practice and of course in practice you
have to think about where you're going
to deploy this
um perspective deploy the kind of
technology that would you know
um ensue from that perspective of course
we're talking about communication we're
talking about a universal world of lots
of creatures like me and you so now we
get to
um the next level of application of
these existential imperatives in the
context of not just intelligent behavior
and just Open brackets Behavior here is
quite important you know often I hear
um underwriting the move from AI
artificial intelligence to IA where it's
intelligent age
artifacts with agency that do have
behaviors that have a centered kind of
behavior and or at least an intelligent
uh kind of behavior close brackets
um so um we're now moving from
um thinking about a single thing a
particle or a person or a computer
and thinking now about having lots of
things that are talking to each other
and they're coexisting so now we're in
the world of distributed intelligence
distributed cognition
um one thing which um you know you
mentioned explicitly this notion of
belief for sharing so now we're in a
different kind of world where we're
thinking okay we think we understand the
imperatives for good behavior the
necessary kinds of behaviors that you
know you you identity highlighted
curiosity I think is absolutely Central
in terms of
um
you know whole marketing and character
drives and the kinds of behaviors that
you and I engage with are truly
intelligent or sentient Behavior would
entail but now the idea is well what
would that look like and
um when you've got lots of these things
talking to each other well we know what
it looks like we talk to each other
literally so it's all about language
it's all about uh belief sharing shared
intelligence
um
distributed cognition would be one thing
you might find in the in the Life
Sciences
um if you were a computer scientist it's
all about sort of the right kind of
message passing on very very large
Factor graphs
um if you're if you're a linguist or
into uh Evolution and psychology it's
all about neat cultural Niche
construction the emergence of language
and so I found that quite fascinating as
something which you know you really had
to get on top of to think well what next
and what kind of Technologies would you
need to realize and what would they look
like
um
you know one way that's been framed to
me by my new friends now in Industry
um is you know what would what's it
going to look like what what is
um AI or now IA going to look like
um in the future
taking the kind of perspective you know
over the decades or indeed centuries
where you're moving from sort of the
Industrial Age to the age of information
and I think the notion now is we're now
come to the end of the age of
information now we're in the age of
intelligence and think about what what
that might look like and how would one
equip people with the right kind of
technology and infrastructure
um to you know to realize the potential
of shared intelligence essentially
yeah that's very interesting so we spoke
with Luciano floridi at Oxford and he's
invented this philosophy of information
he talks about the infosphere and how
we're we're out we now have third order
technology essentially so things like
Amazon and Facebook and he talks about
the um diminishment of our ontology and
agency in the info sphere and using this
information as a substrate thing I think
is very interesting because that's kind
of alluding to what you're going to but
um you said something actually in your
paper which gave me pause for thought
you said the AI age may end up being a
distributed network of intelligent
systems which interact frictionally in
friction frictionlessly in real time and
composing to emergent forms of
intelligence at subordinate scales as
you were just alluding to and the nodes
of such a distributed interconnected
ecosystem May then be human users as
well as human designed artifacts that
embody or Implement forms of
intelligence now this really did make me
wonder because is I think we're already
there now and uh so when when we had
Floridian he was talking about how our
digital identity has already distributed
we were consumers and then we became
barcodes and now there's this kind of
infinite fractionation in the info
sphere and it's almost as if Humanity
isn't the substrate anymore information
is the substrate and he said you can
devalue human skills you can remove
remove human responsibility you can
reduce human control you can erode human
self-determination but the rock that
thought that little drop of water was
nothing 18 years later has a hole in it
because drop after drop after drop the
drop Will shape the stone will shake the
Rock and I think what he meant by that
is being ensconced and enmeshed in
technology to such a high degree and
information being the first class
citizen in our society is kind of
truncating our very existence I mean
what would you say to that
beautifully effectively expressed very
poetic I'd have to think about that very
carefully I'm sure there are deep truths
there
um and certainly from uh from the point
of view of a physicist your information
is obviously
um the thing it is it is uh in many
respects the you know the substance of
our universe and our existence and you
know also acknowledging that energy is
information and energy is just a
potential and so we're all about we're
all in the game of realizing Potentials
in a sort of folk psychology sense but
also literally in terms of minimizing
certain potentials for example
self-information uh would be the the
free energy potential that you're that
you're minimizing the surprise and again
coming back to this sort of making you
know belief sharing in the service of
minimizing uh minimizing a surprise and
realizing our our potential
um so I but I don't see that as a
negative thing I think that's just an
acknowledgment that you know at the end
of the day
um the way that we model and articulate
and talk about
um ourselves our lived World whether
we're a Quantum physicistic
um a statistical
um
physicist or a classical physicist or I
have an interest in our in the
equivalent mechanics at each of those
levels it's all about information it's
all about the probability of being in
this particular State you just take the
um the negative log of that that is the
self-information of this particular
state so it's all you know if you look
at quantum physics you know what else is
there it boils down to
um and it's sort of most Elemental and
scale free or background free form and
Quantum information Theory and so if you
can reduce it to you know to Quantum
information Theory which many people
including friends of Mike Levin and
think one can then I think there's a
there's a deep truth that we we are just
um realizations of information and
particularly from my perspective of
course
we being a thing what what kind of
information
processing would be apt to describe us
that could be you know articulate in
terms of quantum information Theory it's
belief updating so we come back to the
Bayesian mechanics that you can put on
top of this underlying
um you know sort of information
theoretic probabilistic description of
the world
um but I guess so reading between the
lines and the twinkling your eye is the
idea that he's trying to get across is
that may be quite bad for Humanity is
that is that the idea is it well that's
what that's what he thinks and I mean he
thinks you're a computationalist uh you
you think that information is is the
kind of primary substrate and in a way
he's also worried that information is
becoming the primary substrate but the
big difference between you and 3D is
that he thinks that humans are special
he thinks that we like can't we have
autonomy we choose our own actions you
know we can't be replica in silicone so
he thinks essentially that there's no
such thing as general intelligence that
there's just algorithms that perform
skills and it's our Humanity which is
being truncated I see right okay well
I'm I would be very sympathetic to that
yes I mean we are special
um kinds of intelligence
um and one could equip that argument
with you know what is the definition of
sentience what's a bright line between
you know a very clever thermostat
um or some machine learning artifact
um or a virus and you and me and I I
think there is a bright light and of
course you've just said what it is it's
it's the autonomy it's the agency its
ability to plan and the all the
existential imperatives that
um that underwrite that planning and
then we come back to curiosity so but if
he's saying that um
the fact we are here Belize the fact we
are curious creatures and because we are
um
we populate a universe that comprises
creatures like us we're all curious
about each other then I would certainly
say yes that is a definitive aspect of
us which is not found I think
um I'm just thinking Capricorn I'm sure
you can find examples but um you know I
don't and the kind of artificial
intelligence that we currently interact
with in exchange with
you don't have that planning and
curiosity they don't have the you don't
have baked into the optimization
um framing of you know what makes a
viable or a good bit of intelligence you
don't actually have baked in universally
um this expected information came this
curiosity and in that sense
um I think it's probably absolutely
right
um and in a sense the belief sharing
um
getting to that the right kind of belief
sharing of the kind that the white paper
was talking about is predicated on the
notion that you will now be able to
equip sentient artifacts that we make
with curiosity and maybe asking well
what are they going to be curious about
their world what is their world it's you
and me and the other artifacts so
they're only going to be curious about
you and me they're going to be
interested in you and me
um so we're talking about you know
a Siri or a Google Maps and starts to
ask you questions instead of you asking
them questions so that I think that's
that's one way of eluding his his sort
of rather dystopian
attitude to the the the information is
King I think information is King relief
updating is King that you know
um belief updating is you know
um of course the thing that
um ensues once you act upon the world to
do some smart data mining to you know to
respond to some epistemic affordances
um and you know the question then is
your what kinds of systems do that and
at the moment I would is probably just
us there are other examples of some
beautiful examples in um so Active
Learning using machine learning you know
to design your own experiments and
automize the actual experiments and say
drug Discovery or um
molecular biology
um so I mean the the there is a long
history both in statistics and in
machine learning of active learning
um that I think does have the potential
but I don't see it really being
um well
from what I understand in discussions I
don't see that being a Bedrock of the
way forward an explicit part of the
design for yeah and from an age of
intelligence that is
um puts us sympathetically in an
ecosystem of intelligence
um and that's really what that white
paper was trying to think yeah what
would it look like to
um and what would happen if your Google
Maps became very curious about you
particularly
[Music]
um
well there are two sort of um sort of
metaphors here which are which which
might sort of
um ground
the you know the frame
um the framework or the perspective that
um I'm trying to think about this this
worry
um one which I found very helpful
um again coming from my colleagues in in
industry is just trying to explain that
you know the nature of
shared intelligence and distributed
intelligence
um and the the analogy here would be the
brain you know you've got really smart
little elements little neurons I mean
they're really smart and in fact if you
get into the weeds of dendritic
computation incredibly smart little
things
um that are in receipt of their
Sensations and they act by sort of
pinging they don't know who they're
pinging but they're pinging away
certainly a little action potential or
messages down down the axons and the
wires that are emitted from from the
nerve cells and you've got you know 10
billion of these things and they're all
very very smart but would you call any
one of them autonomous would be called
would they have agency and in an
elemental sense I think they do
um but it's when you put them all
together lots and lots of little smart
things together do you get this emergent
kind of intelligence that you could
undeniably say
um has the capacity to roll out into the
future to you know
generate fantasies or
counterfactuals that are all conditioned
upon what I'm going to do next where I
now becomes this Collective so this is
the kind of emergent
behavior that emerges from getting lots
of little smart things to talk to each
other in the right kind of way so that
that that's you know I think quite a
helpful analogy by what is meant between
uh about shared intelligence and what
might you know might arise clearly a lot
of these little smart brain cells would
be analogous to you and me and a lot of
other a lot of others would be all kinds
of apps and you know uh you know giving
you now the potential to see through the
eyes of of any smart app
that knows what you want to know and is
curious about what you want to you know
to find out again coming back to this
notion that
um
belief sharing I think is already there
in the context of say yo uh Sat Nav you
know I
um share my beliefs about my preferred
States would be my characteristic
preferences are one part of the you know
the imperative for policy selection or
the good plans I share that with in
terms of a destination with some shared
World model or shared narrative between
me and my Sat Nav
um you know in this instance of a
geographical World model
um and then it has beliefs about the
best policy it makes a little plan and
then it shares its beliefs with me again
so I think the you know that to the
extent that um your colleague in Oxford
was was uh saying we're already there I
think that that's absolutely right I
mean you know we already have this kind
of belief sharing
um I think that the move though is
um
to make that a much more symmetric
belief sharing you know I'm asking the
app for its beliefs for it's I'm asking
it to behave as a recommender
um and um and it only knows what I sell
it so it has no autonomy but if it was
now in a position to actively smartly
resolve its uncertainty about me the
user then it's much more of a sort of
you know
a balanced symmetrical dianic
interaction between me and the app and
the agenda here is not to create paper
clips or make money the agenda remember
is just to resolve uncertainty to say to
curiosity and to move towards a state of
Greater Mutual understanding so that
that that that that's a sort of the the
non-dystopian view of of uh you know
information sharing so um Shane Legg
said that his definition of intelligence
is the ability of an agent and we're
using words here like agent we'll get to
those words in a minute being able to
solve a variety of tasks in different
environments Francois Chalet said it's
efficiently creating abstractions given
limited prize and experience
pay Wang says it's the adaptation
efficiency over finite resources
so um when you look at definitions of
intelligence typically they focus on
principle and function which I think
your one does or capability or behavior
or structure
now um
the interesting thing about the
principal one in particular is I think
it's the least anthropomorphic and I
think yours is the least anthropomorphic
definition I've ever heard of
so um and also this concept of um
grounding in the physicality of
information rather than reality itself
and whether they are the same thing of
course is a philosophical discussion
that maybe we'll park for another time
um but yeah how how would you contrast
your definition of intelligence from
these other ones
um I think you've already done that you
you've just said it's you know it's it's
a a minimal
um essentially a physics-based
definition of intelligence which
requires you know a move or indeed a
complete commitment to stay in the space
of information and information
geometries and belief updating
um so
um having said that I think all of those
definitions touch upon some essential
aspects of intelligence every one of
them rang true you know to my ears
um and I could read every one of those
as being one
um key foundational aspect of what would
emerge if any self-organizing system
managed to supervision and coexist with
other self-organizing systems
um from the point of view of you know of
the free energy principle
um the sort of
um
first principle approach so there are no
axioms or no assumptions the question is
not um you know what is quintessentially
anthropomorphic
um the question is what emergent
properties of certain kinds of
self-organizing systems would qualify as
having that that bimetic and then
ultimately anthropomorphic aspects to
them you don't even have to go to
anthropomorphism I mean if you um
we're talking as you have been to Mike
Levin and his friends you know they
would talk about basal cognition they
would talk about you know uh just a
multicellular organism is a beautiful
construction of uh that rests upon
autopriest self-assembly of individual
cells but also cells of cells and you
know how does a surface cell and
epithelium know that it's on the surface
and how does that individuate the
internal cells of an organelle or an
organ and from the rest of the
environment so the you know
the kind of
um
intelligence that has this
anthropomorphic feel
I think people are are also seeing in
biotic self-organization that would be a
long way away from the kind of
psychological psychology intelligence
that we're talking about and yet it
rests upon exactly the same kind of
mechanics and you know for me that would
be the basic mechanics that come from
the uh the Dynamics of systems that are
self-organizing open systems that are
self-organizing
um so
you know you talked about sort of
adaptation
um has been one aspect one common theme
in in the um the sequence of definitions
you gave I think does speak to this
bright line between uh basal cognition
and biotic self-organization biological
intelligence of the kind you can read in
many many different ways your your DNA
for example your genotype is an
intelligent information uh accumulating
device on the point of view of evolution
you know it it stores all the
information about what it would require
to build a phenotype that's fit for
purpose in this particular environment
so you know that's a kind of belief
updating that's a kind of intelligence
but it doesn't have what we were talking
about before which is this capacity to
plan Evolution doesn't plan you could
also argue that the the World Wide Web
doesn't plan
um Google Maps You could argue it
doesn't plan to a certain extent because
it's certainly so what's the difference
the difference is I think implicit in at
least the first two of your of your
definitions which is this notion of
counter factual Futures this notion of
um you know imagining a future or
um putting it another way having a world
model or a generative model
um that explains things that are not
tied to the moment so if you're a
physicist what you're talking about is
now a probabilistic mechanics a Bayesian
mechanics or possibly just you know an
information theoretic mechanics based
upon paths through time so we're talking
about things like the pathogical
formulation and you know but crucially
we're talking about trajectories that
don't that cannot be localized to this
point in time that necessarily entail
the future and indeed the past so I've
you know that notion of freeing yourself
in a you know the account of the name of
the philosopher now I can remember them
I just can't pronounce it so I'm gonna
pretend I can't remember well there are
people who there are um there are
philosophical schools that emphasizes
temporality aspect now you know and if
you just look at physics uh look at
contributions of Richard Feynman for
example yeah it's all about the
pathological formulation
um uh and um
so I think as soon as you talk about
um the elements to which the information
geometry is an intelligence and autonomy
um all of these things could apply are
not States they are trajectories
dynamics narratives paths
um that have this um this sort of
future-pointing aspect
um then being able to select among
different futures
becomes an emergent property of this
kind of sense making this kind of
autopoiesis under red as a Bayesian
mechanics of self-organization and just
thinking about your definitions they all
have that aspect of choosing among
different futures or considering or
having abstractions
um uh you know about what might happen
if if this so for me that that is one
way of expressing
curiosity because to be curious you have
to imagine well what would happen if I
did that
and what would I know if I did that
but you'll have to imagine it before
it's actually happened which you know is
is for me the big bright line between
um you know between the anthropomorphic
kind of intelligence and the
intelligence you find in the thermostat
or in a you know A variation autoencoder
yeah and later on we will decompose the
different aspects of cognition and I
think as well as thinking it can be
knowing and acting as well and we'll
we'll talk to that but you said words
you know action agent per set goal plan
behavior and
I guess and I I posed this to Levin as
well it feels like these are terms that
we understand because we have cognitive
priors like a gentiveness and so on
these are things that that we understand
that might actually only be a lens into
something far more complicated and just
to touch on the um information traversal
points over a geometry that's very
interesting and I'm no expert but I
think the medial temporal lobe deals a
lot with spatial contiguity and we have
grid and place sales etc etc so it you
know at a macroscopic level in our brain
it's a first-class citizen but there's
also this hierarchy isn't there
um when does it start happening you know
do single cell organisms plan into the
future
and to the previous point is planning
necessarily A reductive lens of
intelligence
if you feel like you brought up loads of
interesting things there you caught me
by the reductive lens that's a lovely
phrase what does that what does that
mean well um I I didn't I didn't mean it
in a pejorative sense but when when we
use words like you know like we we say
intelligence must do X Y and Z in this
plan it must reason it must act and we
have this cybernetic Loop and so on and
I I have a theory that
this is just the way we understand
things I see and and in a sense it's a
lens on to a much more complicated thing
and and the reason this is interesting
is
the reason why we have people like John
settle who says that the um the
impenetrable Realm of the subjective
experiences Beyond function Dynamics and
behavior it's a little bit extra and and
even and morality is another example
we'll talk about that later that feels
like it's something which is a little
bit extra so there's always this
question of to what extent is
intelligent behavior deducible from the
models and the words that we use
yes I think that's a fundamental Point
uh you said um
okay now I understand what a reductive
lens is I like that I like
um I think for many reasons of course
because
um well first of all
um it certainly is not uh you I don't
think it could ever be using a
pejorative sense um but it does speak to
um two fundamental themes which is
um
the the way that we do make sense of our
world
through core screening through reducing
uh through having
um intuitive models of the way that the
world Works
um that ultimately could be
um
seen as language words could be I think
could also be seen at regardless physics
and maths as well to be quite honest
um you know these at least the more I
read about about you know modern
mathematicians and physicists talking
about that you know their skills and and
the the legacies that they that they
enjoy the more I realize it's all
changing all the time it's just another
kind of reductionism
um but language particularly but it's a
right kind of reductionism and I guess
what you're saying is that you know
um we have this um way of summarizing
classifying certain kinds of behavior
which may not truly reflect the
underlying complexity the beauty of
what's going on underneath that at that
at that point I ever go the other way I
would actually say that do not properly
reflect the underlying Simplicity of
what's going on to be quite honest uh
you know and this comes back to you know
the um unashamed use of phrases like
sort of existential imperatives and
self-evidencing yeah we're just here
we're just we just have characteristic
sets we're just realizations of some
glorious
um launch van equations and all these
stories about sort of uh belief updating
and
um sentience and intelligence and just
reductive stories that make sense of you
know what we you know what um what we
must
um or can if indeed to a certain extent
the free energy principle itself I think
is a reductive story of that kind uh
yeah when I say if you look at things
through the lens of Bayesian mechanics
as if I think the 300 principle is
another example of of this kind of
reductive thing it's looking at
something which is inherently much more
simple than the lens through which
you're looking at which is the basic
mechanics and the free energy principle
so I think that's absolutely right a
really interesting idea
um
at another level I think it speaks to
some key issues you know I mean you're
um you you you're often
um then confronted with you know okay
I'm talking with you about agency and
agents and me and you uh so
what license is that what aspects of my
implicit World model generative model
endow me with the sense of me and you
and indeed me as agent and you know what
would that look like if I Stripped Away
um different levels of meta awareness or
meta cognition if you're a psychologist
and just had a minimal selfhood
um you know is just be having plans
um sufficient to call me an agent even
if I don't know if I'm an agent if I
have plans who else is going to act you
know enact those plans
I mean I would love to go there slightly
later but there's so much we can say
about
um agency and the boundaries and also
the causal pressures between agents and
also whether you can think of boundaries
as being Observer relative but I just
really wanted to go to the universal
um algorithm thing that you spoke about
before because I think it's delicious so
um I think it's fair to call you a
Universalist and that and that that's
there are quite a few universalists
actually these are people who think
there's a simple underlying principle
and this is in contrast to what we were
just talking about which is that the the
reality is more complicated than we'll
ever understand and we have a truncated
cognitive Horizon and we as Chomsky says
we just have kind of um simple
Primitives built into us that help us
frame and and understand the kind of
abstraction space within a certain code
but um I was reading Professor
Christopher Summerfield's book at Oxford
I'd interviewed him last week he said in
his book
um could it be that the success of
mammalian brains is not due to any
careful crafting into a mosaic of
different functional subsystems but
instead is merely due to size we know
there's a powerful relationship between
the sheer number of neurons and the
complexity of behavior he went on he
said researchers and neuroscientists
alike such as Carl friston and uh Jeff
Hawkins and even Andrew have flirted
with the idea that there might be a
single algorithm which underpins
intelligence with the brain acting like
a massive TPU repeating instructions Ad
nauseam to generate complex Behavior so
it's a fascinating idea is that a fair
summation
yes what's a TPU in this oh well a
tensor Pro programming unit it's a very
powerful
um computer right yeah I've learned
another new acronym my world is full of
new acronyms right okay
um yeah
um so what what his argument there is
it's something to do with
um scale and size is is that what not
not only that I mean we'll we'll get to
there's a guy called Rich Sutton and he
he had this um you know bitter lesson
essay and it's a warning against hand
crafting
um structures architectures because at
bottlenecks it doesn't scale so this
Universalist idea is that you know maybe
and and Jeff Hawkins says the same thing
he's got this thousand brains theory of
intelligence yes and the idea is that
there's a very simple underlying
algorithm or principle and you just
replicate it you scale it up or out
and that produces emergent intelligence
right yes well okay then I am a
Universalist yes
um uh so
um
you know but both of those the way you
described it do speak to some um I think
very pressing issues about
um structures and structural learning
um uh that you know you could either
um read from the point of view of
machine learning and sort of graph
learning what's the rights you know how
many layers does this particular deep
learning architecture need or what kind
of factorization are I going to put in
play
um
or if you uh
um you know
um radical con a radical constructivist
this you know that's where you know I've
often heard people like Josh Tenenbaum
for example think about sort of
structural learning and
um from the point of view of the
universalists have now I've learned that
new word now that's good so as from as a
Universalist
um then you are certainly looking for uh
the one principle
that is redeployed at successive scales
um and
um that should be a sufficient
explanation for those things that show
um emergent behaviors at particular
scales so I think that you know that
that is absolutely true
and again you can read this from the
point of view of a mathematician from
the point of view of
um the renormalization group and what
does that mean well it just means that
you know if I take lots and lots of
little things
um and I start coarse grading them in a
particular way
um then if I want to describe the
behavior of all the elements at one
scale of organization say molecules or
cells or people
um
then if I can write then down their
Dynamics in terms of say A lagrangian
you know some way of summarizing their
dynamics that um and all the things that
um a company or ensue from this don't uh
that Dynamics
um then if I do my core screening
um and then look at the collective the
average Behavior obviously lots of cells
a place cell or your entire medial
temporal or entire person
um at a more macroscopic level then I
should be able to recapitulate the same
functional form of the Dynamics and or
the lagrangian
um so from that point of view
um you have a a particular kind of
universalism that is actually scale free
because you get the same principle
emerging at every level and that's that
is basically
um one
um one way of looking at the deployment
of the free energy principle is asking
what would it look like when deployed at
different scales so you can deploy it at
the level of dendritic self-organization
you can deploy it at the level
um of
um you know Neuroscience you could
deploy it at the level of morphogenesis
and cellular pattern formation we've
done that with Mike Levin
um
the idea being that the this the same
Universal principle works at every every
level then the interesting game comes
between the coupling between the levels
how does one level constrain an inform
or contextualize the level below and
vice versa you know and this I think is
a really important sort of um issue
which is probably well rehearsed in many
different disciplines ranging from say
Evolution so Evolution as a free energy
minimizing process where free energy is
literally the
um the mark the negative abound on the
negative
um log marginal likelihood
um I namely the likelihood of finding me
this phenotype here with sampling random
from a population
um how does that scale of a free energy
Self auto poetic process you know
natural selection basic model selection
if you're a statistician how does that
provide constraints on the exactly the
same principles
um of active inference and learning
in developmental time for any given
phenotype and then the that would be the
top down conversation the bottom-up
conversation from one scale to the next
scale would be you know how does my
behavior my experience experience
dependent plasticity mind evidence
accumulation all my good pays in
decisions how does that now mean I
contribute to the gene pool at the uh at
The evolutionary level yes so that yeah
that that would be what we're reading it
the other way of reading it of course is
just if you're designing
um a TPU or deploying a TPU
um you've got you've got message passing
on some graph what is a graph well it
only has interesting structure in virtue
of the
um the sparsity or the connections that
are not there otherwise it's a full
graph and it's not very useful for
anybody speaking to Chris's
Christopher's uh uh you know
you know two two big too many neurons
um you can't you you necessary to have
to have a sparsity to fit all those
neurons into I would put it the other
way around though I I would say that
anything that is adaptive and has this
size uh you know what properties must it
possess and I would I would suggest that
it has to comply with the principles of
um self-evidencing
um where evidence now is the marginal
look the marginal likelihood that can
always be read as accuracy minus
complexity so as if it exists and it's
big it's got to be minimally complex
what does that mean it's going to have
the smallest degrees of freedom the
minimum number of Connections in so you
should be able to predict the sparsity
from the first principles at every scale
so that sparsity defines the nature of a
graph and indeed if you're talking about
anything that's deep in a hierarchical
sense all you're saying is there's a
particular kind of graph that I have in
mind and it it you know has a certain
sparsity structure but crucially it's a
sparsity structure that allows me to
call it a hierarchy it means that there
are no connections that transcend unlike
a sort of you know a U-shaped uh what is
it no it's still hierarchical to anyway
sorry I'm getting a bit distracted like
the choice so I mean I think that's sort
of um the notion of
um coupling between different
hierarchical scales is absolutely
crucial from many different perspectives
renormalization group Evolution
um you know getting the right graphical
architecture on your message passing
scheme and computer design so yes I
wanted to bring that up but I discussed
um
exactly the same thing with lemons so
morphogenesis and
the rungs of the emergence ladder and
the causal pressures between those rungs
and you know philosophers like George
Ellis said that you only have causation
between the levels and Douglas
hofstatter and go to Leisure bark and
the strange loot is that there's a very
complex Panner play of causal pressures
between the scales and like that I gave
the example to Michael my mind is an
emergent phenomenon and I command in my
hand to move and he said that at
different scales you get different
amounts of work and actually I think if
you get into integrated information
Theory it's kind of talking to that a
little bit and and I think you think of
Consciousness as having a lot of
information processing going on because
it's at the top of the stack to some
extent but do you have any intuition on
how that information is kind of
partitioned between the scales and how
those causal pressures work between the
scale yes I do wonderful you're very
well read aren't you uh so it's nice
that you you mentioned George Alexander
I use the word top-down causation
exactly the spirit that he writes about
it it's wonderful I have literally had
him in mind but yeah so I was hoping if
he ever hears it he'll he'll know that I
was talking about him so he's exactly
that and it always makes me a bit queasy
when I use the word emergency which I
think since some people say there's no
top-down causation in emergentism but I
I don't fully understand the philosophy
of it but it just don't acknowledge that
sorry yes I've distracted myself from
your really important question which
oh yeah see
um so the the different scales
um of a Bayesian mechanic
self-organization viewed through the
lens of basic mechanics
um I think
um what we've just been talking about
and I would imagine with
um with Mike as well a lot of focus of
uh here in that kind of work
um is
um I hesitate to use it but I will use
it spatial scales you know how how do
elements how do single cells assemble
into multicelli where why what we are
how on Earth can you um envisage the
emergence of multicellular organisms
those Mike's done some beautiful
theoretical work you know several years
ago now just just think about it to be a
skin cell to be an epithelium means you
have to sacrifice the ability to
reproduce so it's if you like completely
paradoxical from the point of view of
natural selection you have to sacrifice
yourself with a greater good so there
are you know there's some wonderful
questions about uh about
um
um cells of cells and of cells and cells
as you build up to different levels of
spatial scale but I think your question
will be better addressed from the point
of view of temporal scales
um and again you come back to this um
universalism
um now I'm getting fluent using that
word
um where you've got the same principle
playing out yeah exactly the same
principle exactly the same mechanics the
same lagrangian
um playing out at different scales that
um where each scale contextualizes and
has this circular causality at the
bottom map and top down
um aspects to it in play so my favorite
example of this is just to
um look at a succession of belief
updating
processes from the very very fast which
would be from the point of view of um
your sentient machines it would be
inference inferring states of the world
as they are in the moment so State
estimation Bayesian filtering
um everything that um you know speaks to
some kind of situational Awareness on
the basis of some smart and hopefully
smartly sampled data
um
and then we move to the next level I'm
going to skip attention and precision
but there is an intermediate level which
usually um in in neurosciences has a
time scale of you know your hundreds to
milliseconds to seconds but I'm gonna
I'm gonna jump straight to learning so
what's learning well it's just slow
inference it's just basically
um slow belief updating
um where the states that matter now are
equipped with another kind of label
which we call parameters or weights in
machine learning in a neural network
um but they're just random variables
that are brought to the table to explain
uh or part of our world monologi model
but they're special
um kinds of parameters because they
change very very slowly
um and then you move well okay so those
are two levels what about turtles all
the way down and Turtles all the way up
okay what's the next level well the next
level is now the structure so now for
any given graph for example
um that is equipped with edges and those
edges will have to have some
um slowly very varying parameters
um that describe the you know
um the nature of the message passing on
those edges
um there will be
um there will be a you are conditioning
up on a particular structure and you
know is there a connection there is it a
hierarchical is it heterochical is it
you know are you net is it
um is it a Transformer it was a
convolutional neural network you've seen
this wonderful evolution of structures
in machine learning over the past few
decades as people try out different
structures and you know somewhere for
one kind of application of the work for
others but um from the point of view of
your question what we are seeing is a
kind of structure learning that's
playing out over years so this but it's
exactly the same principle it's this
free energy minimization but just in
this instance the free energy now is a
pathogical it's just the average over a
long period of time which is the um
which is the exactly the quantity that
people doing
um structure learning or Bayesian model
selection use when adjudicating between
different graphs usually
um of complex system models for example
um it you know and you could argue that
now
um over
um several tens of years or hundreds of
years that you're exactly the same maths
could be leveraged to provide a formal
description of natural selection as
Bayesian model selection exactly the
same things you're doing now when you're
selecting whether to speak or whether
not to speak or trying to infer
selecting the right hypotheses about you
know the narrative that you you have in
your head that makes sense of what I'm
saying
um exactly the same maths and mechanics
is unfolding over the Millennia
um you know in terms of in Terms in
terms of evolution so I think that's a
nice example of the separation of
temporal scales but the conservation of
exactly the same principles that have
this information geometry and implicitly
intelligence in of a basal sort I use
the word basil because that's what Mike
Levin and Chris fields and Jim Clay's
really like using is it's this notion
that
um basal cognition and basal
intelligence transcends
physics psychology and biology
um it's all the same thing this is a
line from Chris Fields there's a friend
of uh
um and I think that's great A Great
Notion um and I think one can do that
very gracefully by being a Universalist
and just by finding the right principle
the right sort of reading of Dynamics
and you know that reading you know for
me is the information geometry that um
that that supports the belief updating
I was going to do Markov blankets later
but it feels relevant now
and maybe we should bring a bit of
continuous versus discreeting so a few
things came to my mind when you were
talking about that first of all we think
of emergence over time and
self-organization over space and I guess
it just occurred to me that are we only
interested in time and space when we
talk about this kind of structural
learning and then um with these Markov
boundaries I had only thought of them
um
in at one point in time but you could
actually think of a kind of
three-dimensional markup boundary um
over over time as well now just to
remind our audience um blanket States
facilitate the interaction between the
internal and the external conditional
independencies the external states are
independent from the um the internal
States as long as we know the
intermediate blanket States
now um to get to the uh to a core issue
that we've been modeling complex systems
you know like where do you draw these
boundaries and is it boundaries all the
way down
yes
um
so I I think you're absolutely right
this is the perfect time to bring up the
sort of uh I hadn't really thought about
the notion of boundaries in time and
sort of uh
um that's intriguing so but you
distracted me I'll think about that I'll
think about that after our conversation
um but no certainly so
um there's certainly a lot of current
interest in um taking the notion of
Markov blankets which is foundational in
this sort of reductionist lens of the
free energy Principle as a Bayesian
mechanics
um you know the one could could
summarize but the basic mechanics of the
free energy principle is simply just
another kind of uh quantum mechanics or
statistical mechanics that inherits just
from this partition that is the Markov
blanket that separates the the inside
from the outside yes
um now um and of course there are lots
of next issues about one how do you
identify those Markov blankets and how
long do they endure for
um so there's lots of interest in that
at the moment but one very simple
approach to
um the question how long do they endure
for is to say well that's not the right
question because we've just talked about
separation of temporal scales so you
have to say at what temporal scale well
you uh operationally Define the Markov
blanket as the 10 the time over which it
exists uh and what would that look like
then when you're suddenly now think
about
um this situating that Temple scale
within the context of a larger temporal
scale so what you now have is a a
picture where big mark off blankets
blankets and blankets things that define
say you were you and me or cultures or
um
Nations States or institutions that
um outlive say species
um
these big ones uh last for a long time
but they contextualize and provide
constraints on the mark of blankets at
this at a smaller scale that last for
very uh for for much um much shorter
periods of time and so on all the way
down so that at some level say at the
the molecular level from your
perspective these Markov blankets may
only exist for nanoseconds or your
milliseconds
um but from the perspective of the
molecule thank you yeah this this is a
lifetime and it's well Happy complying
with or can be understood as
um you know doing its own basal
intelligence doing its own basal belief
updating just automatically for its
lifetime which may only be a few hundred
milliseconds
um you're making sense of its world or
inter being interpreted as having the
sort of um sort of you know biotic
intelligence and self-organization just
because it exists for that period of
time so then again this interesting
question you know how does one time
frame contextualize the other starts to
bite and you know you start to now think
about
um from the point of view of a slower
time scale what would
um a succession of Markov blankets uh
look like
um
and what one immediately
um encounters is the notion of a of a
Wandering itinerant Markov blanket yes
um
we spoke about vagueness on on the first
one so we'll we'll park that the
wandering sets is very very interesting
but um I there were two things that I
that I think I wanted to understand
um you do think that there's a hierarchy
of blankets but I'm interested in
exploring this idea of whether the
blankets could be Observer relative to
use the word could be understood as a
mark of blank there and that brings up
two things to the floor of my mind first
of all the extent to which they are a
lens versus describing something in
reality I see and if they do describe
something in reality you spoke about
this symmetric causal pressures which we
can we can speak to as well but but on
this understood thing it's very similar
to um Wittgenstein said the meaning of a
word is in its use and that meaning in
language is is embedded in pragmatic
actions and the language game and so on
and and then like the the further
thought occurs well maybe the the
understanding of a boundary or a you
know Markov boundary blanket could be um
understood in the context of one's
perspective
right that's great question and
um and I I may be informed by reading
some of the philosophical literature
and I should remind you of course I am
not a philosopher so um so that's
another one I say will be naive
um you need to speak to philosophers
about this but I would I would say the
Markov blanket
um is is something which is metaphysical
um you know it it it is defined by a
particular spasticity structure when
formulating any state space in terms of
Dynamics and specifically you know a
laundroman equation so one talks about
the free energy Principle as a first
principle account
um but it does actually commit to
something it commits to the notion that
there are states and that those states
have a separation of temporal scales
that disambiguates or separates systemic
States from random fluctuations so the
that's all it does there are no more
assumptions and then everything else for
us from that
under the understanding that fourth
sufficiently large systems the
probability of there not being a Markov
blanket is
um zero
um so and this comes back to the sort of
um this uh sparse coupling uh conjecture
um that Christopher I think was alluding
to um or at least we
um we unpacked in terms of this you know
that if a system becomes exists of and
is sufficiently Big it will be sparse
and once it spars there
um with probability one will be Markov
blankets so at no point now have we
introduced the notion of observers we
haven't at this point even introduced
the notion of the free energy principle
we're just saying
um there will be one way of carving up
large dynamical systems or certainly
systems can be expressed as a launch of
an equation or a random dynamical system
um will be ways of carving them up into
one or more Markov blankets at one or
more scale yes um and then the question
is well what um what would it what what
would one uh how would one then describe
um the Dynamics for any given Markov
blanket so you at this point you are at
Liberty if you are simulating a universe
to choose the Markov blanket and the
scale that you want to simulate
if you're part of the system you're not
at Liberty because if you're part of
this system you have your Markov blanket
so all you see are the sensory
Impressions upon your Markov blanket and
you may or may not have active States
and it pixels back to the southern
bright lines that make between agents
and sense making machines that can't act
sessile things so if you're asking
um
I um are the Observer dependent
perspective uh dependent aspects of this
formulation
using Markov blankets as a
epistle logical device not if you're
part of the system it says something
quite profound about what you could you
know what you know what and if you're
being observed by something else if you
believe if your world model is populated
with the fantasy that there are other
observers out there yes um then those
observers will never ever know your
internal States well what about rather
than an observer
um an actor or an agent
and we'll talk about an activism in a
little bit but even at the microscopic
scale there are still affordances and
you gave this beautiful example of um of
a type of species where someone might
kill themselves with a great good and
that that shows the kind of information
sharing that you have in these complex
systems so similarly if I'm an agent in
this system and and I act and and there
are these you describe this cybernetic
Loop and there are these kind of
symmetrical causal pressures and so on
and and and then you almost get this
emergence of the markup blanket
so it's changeable
yes no it certainly
um that's certainly true it is
changeable and it's malleable and it's
self-assembling uh and certainly when
you have Markov blankets and Markov
blankets and coalitions and mark off
blankets for example or formation of in
groups and out groups and the like you
would expect there to be a a you know a
dynamics of of the Markov blankets or
who you're relating to so you know the
sparsity uh structure and who I talk to
and who I listen to and you know what
social media uh you know I I commit to
all of these things are
um products of or Reflections and can
all be articulated in terms of you know
wandering Markov blankets now that
that's absolutely true
um I I thought you were you you were
asking
um
something more about
um whether the Markov blanket is part of
a realist metaphysical description or
whether
yeah I mean there is another argument
that if you if you now play God and you
now put your Universe in in a computer
and now to simulate and and write papers
about your simulated Universe where you
can see the inside you know the internal
States next to all states then you know
I think you're in a different world
um
um just again I repeat that something
quite profound about the um the
questions of you know what is it like to
be something
um
are interesting because from the point
of view of the free energy principle
what is it like to be something means
that someone's asking that question so
they are a thing and they're asking
about another thing so now they're
asking questions what is it what um what
is it like to
um know the internal states of a Markov
blanket but by definition you can never
know them so there is something
impenetrable about being something else
so it's a question which is unanswerable
it's unknowable
um
um so if um from that point of view I
think there's something uh beyond the um
the sort of the epistemology of you know
of Markov blankets but if you're just
simulating cells or people or you know
doing multi-agent simulations then
obviously you could you can choose where
to put your blankets and you can you you
can just use them as a device to
um to understand
self-organization to simulate it and to
predict and I think in that instance you
know the
you you could deploy your mark of
blankets wherever you wanted to whatever
any scale you that you you you thought
was interesting for the phenomenon of
Interest that's not quite speaking to
what you're into there which is a
changeability of the the mark of blanket
so well I mean we can get into that um
because if uh and later on we'll talk
about the the real world implementations
of these ideas but um but it but if you
if you did
hard code the the Markov blankets then
you would bottle neck the system
essentially so ideally you you would
actually have the system defined at a
sufficient resolution where all of this
could could emerge um itself
yeah did you cover the point of whether
the blankets can be
um must they be spatially temporally con
you know should they have a spatial
temporal contiguity
and the reason I'm asking that question
is when you think of a blanket
I like it's almost synonymizing it with
an organism and maybe that's a bad thing
to do and you can correct me but but if
we think of um discontinuous blankets in
information geometry that's an
interesting idea because we kind of
visualize them in 3D space
yeah yeah
well certainly they'll have a topology
yeah
um I mean I've noticed earlier on you're
talking about sort of place cells and
grid cells which are you know very
special and beautiful constructs which
speak to a certain continuity or
contiguity aspect yes they suggest that
these um you're coming back to uh
Christopher some of um uh summer fields
um book um you know one way of
understanding the um the Markov blankets
in the brain so you know we've been
talking about Markov blankets
delineating me from a world but of
course um your temporal lobe has a
Markov blanket as it wouldn't be a thing
he would be able to call it a temporal
though so you know the very hierarchy
could also be described now in terms of
um uh Markov blankets within Markov
blankets within Markov blankets and some
really interesting questions about what
that means for what what part of the
brain can know about another part of the
brain and what and what action becomes
and constantly becomes attention yeah I
just wanted to slip that in because I
think that's what was in part what you
were driving out with this sort of
context-sensitive fluid dynamics on in
exchanges between Markov blankets I
think that's incredibly important even
within the brain in Neuroscience this is
basically the the routing of information
the deployment of
um selective attention or sensory
attenuation attenuating ignoring some
signals it is exactly that that makes us
such adaptive context-sensitive
information processing
um machines and of course that is
exactly what you'd have to worry about
when designing a web with routing and
context sensitive you know who do I
listen to uh so you you know this is
really really important
um the um
so the the the the the
emergence of um I think
you're absolute right they will have a
topology and if I were using Markov
blankets and you know I do and many
other people do every day when
um thinking about message passing as a
statistician on Factor graphs or uh
um which are dual to a graphical Model A
probabilistic graphical model of the
system you're trying to estimate or
understand
um
then you know the markup package is just
the um the implicit nodes that that I
you that influence me or that on the
parents and children the parents of the
children yeah and that has enormous
implications for minimizing the
complexity of the message passing
um and you know and I repeat defines the
hierarchy for example
um so Markov blankets there will have a
topology
um probably best understood practically
from the point of view of graph Theory
as opposed to uh
um
um information geometry
but there are special kinds of
connectivity
that you see
um such as Place fields and I'd also say
if you just look at the history of
machine learning there are particular
um kinds of Markov blankets that
characterize the very structure of
certain neural networks I'm thinking of
convolutional neural networks I'm
thinking about you know often motivated
through weight sharing and the like but
you know if you look at weight sharing
as just the kind of stratulations trying
to minimize the complexity part of your
free energy or your
um negative log marginal likelihood
um then what you are doing is finding
the right kind of sparsity fit for
explaining these kinds of data
what uh what what what is the
architectural principle it's it's the
translational invariance of translation
symmetry it's just the contiguity aspect
it's a fact that you are sampling data
that is generated in or from a metric
space that has a well-behaved metric so
I I would say that sort of you know
Place cells and grid cells and many in
many other are thinking about we have
Chris's friend Tim Baron's work for
example
um finding grid like structures
everywhere yes in abstract spaces uh so
what that tells you is that that it's
likely that we live in a world
um where data are caused by samples from
a metric space that has a you know a a
measure to it
um not all spaces do
um I think it would be hard pushed to
find your the right kind of metric for
language for example
um and certainly if you're if you're if
you're sort of building message passing
schemes or um believe propagation
schemes on a factor graph you don't you
don't think about contiguity in a metric
sense you know you don't measure the
distance between one node another node
is it connected or not
um so I think there are some special
um contiguity let's say there are some
special worlds that are recapitulated
that emerge in the internal
architectures of intelligent machines
that have this contiguity property in
virtue of the fact that some aspects of
the causes of the sensorion
are elaborated in a metric space but not
necessarily everywhere and then well I
want to take you back I'd like you for
you I wonder where you want to take me
anyway well I'll finish them because
um
I see uh in the brain and I also see in
the direction of travel in terms of
um building thinking machines
um as you get deeper into these
hierarchies and you go from uh fine
scale to larger scale there is an
interesting move between
um
architectures that would speak to this
metric aspect in space and in time
to a more discretized topological
non-metric representation yes I know I
wanted to touch on that I mean there's a
beautiful example I mean um Christopher
Summerfield talks about Pierce's Triad
and various ways that that we learn
different types of um symbol and
abstractions and so on and there is a
famous experiment in Neuroscience I'm
sure you're familiar with it where they
showed um people pictures in a certain
order and associations and then the same
topological structure was was recovered
I think in in the ntl and and this is
because even though with spatial
temporal contiguity there is a metric
space but the brain learns these kind of
associations and then you can
essentially learn these abstract
Concepts that you know Concepts that
reverberate in our language and
experience they get represented yes and
I completely agree with your um point
about the the Revolutionary idea of the
um the translational local equi variants
you know the the weight sharing with
cnns it's a beautiful idea it's
revolutionized deep learning
so um just to finish off the discussion
on Marco blankets I wanted to talk about
part whole relationships
so um for the benefit of the audience in
logic and philosophy
myriology is the study of parts and
holes that they form whereas in set
theory it's founded on the membership
relation uh between a set and its
elements in myriology emphasizes the
relation between entities which is to
say the inclusion between them so anyway
when considering systems Markov blankets
can Nest into hierarchies and what
connection if any is there you know
between that and the philosophical study
of mariology and um
I was also going to bring in I don't
know if you've heard of hinton's glom
architecture but it it was it came after
capsule networks and it's you know we
were just talking about these wonderful
inductive prayers and deep learning and
and they yeah they make the problem
there are many curses of machine
learning but one of them is kind of like
the cursive optimization and um and
there's a complexity curse as well and
that's why most of these inductive
priors they reduce the size of the
hypothesis set if you reduce it too much
you get approximation error which
doesn't help you either there's curses
everywhere but um but this is a really
interesting prior as well these part
whole relationships
gosh yes there's so many issues you
bring that I'll just reiterate my
favorite one which is the the the notion
of
um these inductive biases minimizing the
complexity I think that's absolutely you
know that's something which is
absolutely Central
um from the physicists perspective you
know this um reading
um
self-organization as self-evidencing
which is a philosophically poetic way of
Simply
um
scribing existence as an optimization
process which you shouldn't really do
it's all it's really a principal at
least action but you can read it as an
optimization process what are you
optimizing the evidence for my world
models what how can I carve up that
evidence complexity and accuracy what
does having a what would I then mean by
optimization well I mean just providing
the simplest account that maintains a
degree of accuracy what do I mean by
simplest minimizing the degrees of
freedom that I use up in providing that
accurate account how do I do that by the
right sparsity structure what does that
mean it just means finding the right
structure and you know you could
actually think of much of evolution and
the trajectory of machine learning
architectures as this game of finding
the right structure that are just these
structural priors
that are apt for describing the kind of
data you know so if you're you've spent
your entire life doing mnist images then
it's going to be the kind of structural
prize that they are that that inherit
from being sampled from a metric space
and you'll have all the convolution I
think the capsule I didn't know I didn't
know about the glom stuff I always like
listening to to Jeff's um
um latest ideas because he's always got
the right kind of intuitions and and
these intuitions are part of the I think
um part of our reflection of um Ashby's
law of requisite varieties exploding
hypothesis space about the various
structures uh yeah
um but certainly the the capsule stuff
and the you know the um one aspect of
structures of graphical models or
implicit Factor graphs when it comes to
implementation which I think is often
neglected
um is the orthogonal direction from uh
orthogonal you know
um in relation to hierarchical
composition and that's the sort of the
breadth of a model in terms of
um having factors that can be separated
so if you wanted to have say scene
construction you wanted to have
um multi-object you know the ability to
track and infer and and um make sense of
data generated by multiple objects what
he is saying well there are multiple
things out there and these things
um again from the point of view of first
principle account have certain
conditional independencies that is
literally revealed by a lack of
Connections in your world model what
would that look like well if you're a
physicist it would just be a mean field
approximation literally factorizing
um introducing conditional
independencies and factorizing a massive
joint distribution any one level in your
hierarchical model into a number of
factors that if you're a neurobologist
would now be functional specialization
and modularity of a fodorian sense you
know what and where in the brain would
be the the conical examples so I looked
at that as um as a move towards paying
more careful attention to the
non-convolutional aspect you know those
things that that actually deny a
translational symmetry tree and actually
let's celebrate the conditional
independencies within any one particular
within one particular scale so my guess
is that I have no idea so I'm talking
from a point of view of complete
ignorance but my guess is that
um if it's an extension of capsule uh
networks and it will have that aspect
it'll have that separability that sort
of things that can do stuff and account
for attributes that are independent from
other attributes or other objects that
are that are conspiring to generate uh
the data and certainly my world of toy
prototypes generative models usually in
Matlab
um you know then all the heavy lifting
is done from the the mapping between the
levels again so all the interactions you
know big red buses there's bignesses
rednesses and bustness these can be
factorized but they all have to conspire
literally through interactions and
highly non-linear
um operators
um and then generating what I would see
if there was a big red bus
um so you know that puts a lot of
pressure on the the likelihood tenses or
the mapping from you know you'll say a
sense an input layer to the the first
hidden layer for example
um and then the sort of leads you into
all sorts of interesting issues about
you know how do you accommodate that
non-linearity and do you uh again as
looking at the evolution of machine
learning architectures as an
evolutionary process
um
you know a relative or you know 108
whatever
um you know that is another aspect of
this sort of structure learning I think
will be very much finessed I think if we
just move to sort of quantum operators
and and just go to discrete State spaces
and in the spirit of quantum blue
gravity I think sort that out and then
we can worry about what particular
nonlinearities uh anyway so I wondered
away what was it what was your question
my point well no this is a wonderful
break point so um before we hit record
we were talking a little bit about chat
gbt and just before we go there because
that's a fun discussion I think one of
the things that really distinguishes
your your line of thinking obviously
there's the uncertainty quantification
so on but some also there's this idea of
an activism and I wanted to just do a
Whistle Stop tour of that as a contrast
to these more monolithic approaches to
AI like like chat GPT so um an activism
contrasts with representationalism which
is this idea that you know I I know
everything about the world inside the
model and um you said that you can't
just think of the brain as some
behaviorist thing it's a dance of
dialogue you act in the environment and
the environment acts on you in a
cybernetic Loop now you also gave the
I'm quoting like an interview that you
did previously you gave the example of
radical inactivism that you can dispense
of representationalism entirely and you
gave this beautiful example of this
walking robot that kind of fell down a
hill and it did so so gracefully it
looked like it was walking it was all in
the body
um you know if the body is sufficiently
tuned to the environment you don't even
need cognition and of course we'll talk
about a decomposition of cognition in in
a minute
um and and you bring in this idea of
circular causality uh so we're causally
embedded in the world
bidirectionally essentially now when we
decompose cognition
um I think of things like thinking and
feeling and knowing and acting and and
the environment and and so on and I I
think this is one of the key things that
distinguishes your line of thought so
could you give us a bit of a Whistle
Stop tour of an activism
yeah so um an activism is at the heart
of um the circuit causality that that
um follows from the very existence of a
Markov blanket
um and a Markov blanket is the thing
that would be it's certainly in my world
necessary for the existence of something
that is demarcated or individuated from
something else so just having a
separation between thing and nothing or
not a thing
um having uh that separation requires
you now to think about the two-way
traffic
um the bi-directional traffic and of
course now you've got um two directions
of travel that can be thought of as
um the agent if you like sensing the
environment
um
on the one hand on the other hand the
agent acting upon the environment or
vice versa you've got now a circular
causality so coming back to sort of the
other the the the the the the notion of
a perception action cycle and this
notion of a dancing and a dadic exchange
which is bi-directional two-way traffic
uh between the two so when you apply the
free energy principle in practice to
um emulate or simulate sentient behavior
and behavior that is predicated on sense
making
um then you are necessarily simulating
action perception Cycles so you're
necessarily inactivist and that's called
active inference so sometimes just for
fun I put an En in front of it called
inactive inference uh I have to say the
active inference was really a nod to
Active Learning it was just it's the
same idea but
um but cast in terms of fast belief
updating as opposed to slow endless
accumulation in terms of learning
contingencies
um so that use of inactive is at the
heart of applications of the free energy
principle and obviously has been at the
heart of I think all right-minded
formulations of behavior and
self-organization since Plato probably
but certainly you know things like
perceptual control theory cybernetics
and you know all of that good stuff
everybody at some point active sensing
um
well you know we'll we'll
um have to commit to this um active
aspect
um even to a certain extent semiotics I
think well now perhaps we shouldn't
gather
um but the so that would be one way of
um sort of celebrating and foregrounding
the role of action
um and
what would that look like from the point
of view of uh machine learning and um
computer science well it would look like
basically smart data mining
um and it would change the nature of the
game from
um Big Data making sense of big data so
having everything on the inside having
access to the entire world
um and then making sense of that and you
know you may ask what does that mean by
making sense of it what's only doing
something with it like generative AI
um versus
um the um the complementary approach
which is much more in line with this
sort of complexity minimization and the
imperatives for the sustainable
self-organizing self-assembling systems
versus smart data
um so the job the action now is it's
basically what moves do I make on the
world to get the right kind of data that
will serve my imperatives what are my
imperatives to maximize the evidence for
my model in the world and if I can do
that by definition my
um I will be there or put another way
around if I you know if I exist then
that is what it looks like I am doing so
you know you talk about the or you
mentioned this notion sort of Monolithic
big systems
um versus small agile intelligent little
agents and go and get the smart data
that they need or that they think that
you need that is exactly
um the sort of picture that underwrites
this notion of distributed cognition and
a different kind of network and a
different way of relating to intelligent
artifacts and information services and
um and apps uh where it's lots of really
small smart things who are actively
getting the right kind of data that they
need to resolve uncertainty about the
context in which they find themselves a
game that you know the complexity
minimization gets in and everything is
really I'm sure we've talked about this
before but I can't resist just
um mentioning it again from the point of
view of sustainability and climate
change you know the direction of travel
of these large and say large language
models for example is it's so wrong uh
wrong from the point of view of the
ideology of climate change but it also
wrong from the point of view of lamb
Downs principle should Escape equality
when read as a thermodynamic corollary
of self-organization and non-equilibria
you know you've got to minimize the
complexity minimize
um all of the internal machinations so
that you you just need the minimal
amount of data expertly handled every
little agent is a good scientists
designing the right experiments and get
the smart data that resolves it's
uncertain about what it doesn't know uh
and then job done if you if you can do
it like that so that would be one
um if you like sort of answer to your
question you know
um the implications and the importance
of inactivism used really just as a
euphemism for an agent that can gather
its own data
the radical activism is I think a more
of a philosophical thing and it's more
of a fun argument and I don't know any
radical in activists so I I you know I I
don't I don't have um I don't have the
right sensibilities uh it's interesting
to really answer this question but it's
from what I understand
um that you know they have um
taking it a little bit too far and a
denying representationalism
um uh to the extent that you know that
you can get a kind of
um
um sense making that doesn't actually
involve any internal Dynamics
um and um you know I'm sure that's true
and I'm sure that you're going to sell
um uh chat sheet GTP to me that's what
one example of this mindless kind of uh
sort of you know enacted uh uh sense
making uh which is the opposite I think
um I would call chat gbt extreme
representationalism all right yes we'll
resist the urge that we'll go there
immediately after this I I promise but
um so clearly we we think that
intelligence does necessitate embodiment
I think that's clear I want to just
explore this Continuum between
um and activism and representationalism
um
this is this is really interesting so um
this comes down to grounding to a
certain extent so cognition must be
grounded
in different domains and in the physical
world possibly in language in acting in
affordances in knowledge as well and so
this is this is a view that that it that
it is grounded let's say in in
affordances but
if these agents these organisms ground
their cognition in affordances then to
what extent could you say they are
learning a world model if that model is
with the lens of an affordance
I think I think even sort of
um reconcile
um very rich representationalism
um in the service of inactivism Simply
by noting that
um in the circular exchange you have to
deploy the right kinds of actions and
that's going to require
um coming back to what we're talking
about before in terms of planning being
able to build the right counter factuals
you know and to do to do that in an
expert way in an intelligent way you
need to be able to represent the causal
contingencies and states of Affairs in
the world at this time upon which you're
predicating your next action so I I'm
now thinking this looking at your your
expressions and and I I now realize that
you've that you were trying to sell a
dialectic between an activism
representationalism for me
um they are the same thing uh you to be
a good in activist you have to have the
right representations if you want to
well may I say good I mean
um good at a particular scale the big
things that survive so viruses don't
need to do much planning
um but things like you and me do need to
do kind of planning so the As you move
up those scales you have to look further
into the future so that we certainly
need representations which is what I
have which um which is why I'll smile
always smile when I think about radical
and activism so if there's no space in
radical and activism for being able to
plan
to imagine scenarios to have narratives
that play out on the inside before
committing and selecting the Right Way
Forward well it's not an app description
of
um certainly cognition
okay it's so interesting because the the
question to me is we just spoke about
this idea of planning potentially
through an information geometry and many
of the abstractions that humans learn
are not grounded in the physical world
at all and that's very interesting and
we can get to how those abstractions are
learned but I guess what I'm saying is
let's say one of these agents in this
multi-agent system
it's traversing this topology
what grounds the states in that topology
well I think that that would be
um ultimately it will be the
transactions
um you know with with the world that
underwrite
um at the lowest hierarchy level all the
generative models of of this
hierarchical sorts of the abstractions
are just the coarse graining
simplifications that you know the the
um the products of literally looking at
at the lower levels of your hierarchy
through a reductionist lens in the right
kind of way that enable you to carve up
the world in terms of these
um in terms of these abstractions which
may live in a non-metric space
um uh they may still have this ordinal
structure you referring to before
um and then what that would mean in the
context of um lots of similar artifacts
who had done the right kind of core
screening would be now the opportunity
for uh direct belief sharing a brain to
brain communication uh speaking to a
friend of mine even as they talk talking
about the distinction between
communicating through
um
the
through sensory
um
um exchanges such as language but what
we're actually doing is basically
directly exchanging beliefs
um of course you could do that directly
in silico you could actually have
messages about what this agent believes
at this abstract level of um of
representation very high in a you know a
hierarchical graphical model it could
pass its sufficient statistics to
another partner somewhere else in the
world Elsewhere on that on that graph so
you do have the opportunity now for
direct belief sharing
um and all sorts of interesting
questions about you know how you'd
engineer that you you know you can't
coming back to this fact you have to
have spasticity in the game you have to
decide where to to send and receive your
beliefs from then we have this sort of
attention and routing problem and then
you have do you have peer-to-peer
communication do you go through a server
can you write that down in terms of
um Quantum information Theory as a
holographic screen and who's you know
having all sorts of really interesting
things but what they speak to
is that you now you're sharing beliefs
literally basically it's probability
distributions as encoded by sufficient
statistics that can be passed
um as messages uh on a on a factor graph
um you're now talking about the ability
for
proper communication of the kind that
has evolved in terms of cultural Niche
construction and evolutionary psychology
that speaks to cultural Niche
construction that we enjoy in terms of
you know the the words that we use and
the exchanges that we use yes yes indeed
so that there are two things to bring in
so knowledge and language and you did
invoke Andy Clark in another interview
which is the extended theory of mine so
it's um one of the five e's in in
cognitive science and the the
communication substrate could of course
it's it's distributed so the two agents
could be referring on missing
information that actually exists perhaps
in another agent or another another
knowledge repository and then we can
also talk to exactly what the role of
language is and how it's compressed how
it represents abstract Concepts and so
on
um so I'm very interested in knowledge
and language I'm not sure if you could
bring those in
right um I'm not sure I can do so
expertly but certainly a part of
learning new things since my foray into
into industry is this notion of
knowledge graphs so if you know if you
read a uh a probabilistic graphical
model
as
um at least its structure as being a
Knowledge Graph then embodied
um in the structure and presumably the
parameters of the connections that
constitute that graphical model that
would be knowledge so for me
um in a very non-mysterous and possibly
too simple-minded away knowledge is just
the product of
um belief updating of a slow kind which
is learning so I know contingencies
um in the sense that I have a suitably
configured and optimized structure and
parametrically weighted
um generative model that can be written
down as a knowledge graph or a graphical
model
um upon which I do my message passing to
do my inference about the particular
context sensitive in the moment kind of
thing so I would put knowledge
um basically as an attribute that is
implicit in a um a graphical
a description of
an implicit generative model or World
model that is actively that is used
actively to do the data mining and to do
the do this inference and and the sense
making and then the language part of it
um would just be that
highest level most coarse grained
summary that is conserved over multiple
agents so just by definition
um if I want to do belief sharing
um I have to
um I have to have a a shared generative
model or a commitment to the same
narrative so that the meaning of what
I'm emitting is received in the right
Spirit or the right frame of reference
by you and indeed
um there's some lovely rhetoric from
Quantum information theory of the kind
of Chris phrenals and Jim claysbrook
have been pursuing where you literally
have to think about the geratin model as
a Quantum frame of reference and we have
to share that in order to communicate so
in this instance the
um the Markov blanket cease ceases to be
just a set of states and see and and
adopts the role of a holographic screen
and action now is writing to that screen
and sensation is now reading from that
screen and there are two agents on
either side so you know whatever is
written is an action but can be read by
something else and then you're looking
at the entanglement which is the
synchrony of mutual understanding that
you know we would aspire to uh through
through uh through through communication
so that that that um but that only works
if if the messages that are written to
the screen or written to the Markov
blanket
um
um have the same kind of interpretation
so it speaks again to this um the fact
that you have to have a good model of
the world and the world has
um and that really means that there's a
kind of entanglement or generalized
synchrony from the point of view it
didn't have consistency between the two
sides of your screen or the two sides of
your Markov blanket or your server
um
which have a you know the right kind of
isomorphism so we're talking about
you're basically a shared narrative that
underwrites any exchange of signals and
again what you know just thinking of of
this from the point of view
um of generalized synchrony what we are
talking about is just the characteristic
uh or the emergence of characteristic
behaviors in any sparsely coupled set or
Ensemble of things that possess Markov
blankets or
um have a separability
um
um what will they ultimately do they'll
ultimately find a a synchronization
manifold they'll find a synchronization
simply because
um this is the
um the most likely state of being and
the most likely stated being is that
which maximizes the marginal likelihood
which minimizes the free energy which
just means that they Now understand and
can infer each other so you know it's
just another expression of this
existential imperative to resolve
uncertainty you have good models of my
world and my world also needs to have
good models of me and if my world is you
you have to have a good model of me and
I have to have a good model of you
ultimately what that means is we're
going to converge on the same model
um yeah I mean what interests me there
is that unlike many other researchers
you're com conflating understanding you
know knowing and intelligence itself
I get I guess so yeah
um so good question
um if intelligence is a process of
belief updating then yes it's just
intelligent intelligence and learning I
just learning knowledge and
intelligently inferring states of
Affairs are just the same process at
different time scales and they both
depend upon each other so I have to have
the right
Neil network of the right weights and
the right learning
to make sense of the data in the moment
and if you think of it from the point of
view of uh weight learning
um either through propagation of errors
or through experience dependent or Spike
timing plasticity in the brain you have
to have the right inference in order to
do the learning so there's again this
circular causality between between the
two scales so knowledge requires the
right inference or state estimation and
state estimation requires the right
knowledge to make sense of of the data
that's being assimilated yes although I
suppose philosophically we could break
it down because you know knowledge might
be the sort of the information
acquisition because knowledge exists
it's quite an interesting illustrial
point actually that knowledge is on
Wikipedia and it's crystallized
knowledge it exists as as a thing but
but the ability to to acquire knowledge
without surprise is is is is your your
form of intelligence but I wanted to
talk about chat GPT just quickly
and it's very interesting because Bing
have just released a new version of
their search engine which integrates
chat GPT
and I've I've been on a bit of a journey
when they released gpt3 in the it was
November 2020 I got access to it I
thought it was garbage it was just
generating a load of rubbish basically
but there were people out there who were
True Believers and they said Tim you're
not seeing it I you know I I I've seen
it and they would show me these
ridiculous examples and I just thought
no you're just Fooled by Randomness
and um and then DaVinci 2 came out about
a year ago and then that that
transgressed the anthropomorphic Fooled
by Randomness threshold so I I started
to be a bit of a Believer I knew it
didn't understand anything but it
started to get very useful when I was
using it for coding and generating
emails and so on
um much to my loss actually because
recently I've been checking code into
the to the repo and my colleagues have
been saying to me Tim it looks like you
used GPT to generate that why is it full
of holes and you have to hold your hand
up in a minute oh yes sir I'm sorry I
just I just checked in some code that I
clearly didn't understand and uh you
know didn't actually save me any time
so sometimes you can see problems with
its generation but it's so plausible
that most of the time they're hidden and
unfortunately if you want to verify that
knowledge you might as well have just
not bothered using GPT in the first
place because you could have just gone
so a little recap it's using a
self-attention decoder Transformer and
that's a neural network architecture
that introduces uh permutation
invariance to Tuple permutation
invariance which turns out to be
extremely useful for language and then
there was this discovery of what's
called in context learning which is
where rather than just getting it to
because it's a generative model it just
generates token token you you insert a
prompt and then continue to generate
from that prompt and people discovered
you could ask it questions
it had this emergent reasoning
capability in Big Air quotes and then
more recently people have done what's
called preference fine tuning which is
that you do some additional supervision
on the top with human reference examples
and that aligns it to humans and makes
it give slightly more politically
correct or you know more sensical
answers so and now it's been integrated
into GPT and that does this retrieval
augmented generation which means rather
than just being a snapshot in time it
will also go out go out to Bing get some
relevant search results incorporate that
into the prompt and then generate from
there and there was this incident a
couple of days ago where Bing had this
successful launch to much fanfare and
then people looked at the results it was
generating including fight you know one
of the the things was give me um a
comparison between the financial results
of Lululemon and some other company and
it was just hallucinating the the
results it gave weren't even in the
document and the product managers at
Microsoft didn't even themselves bother
to check the truthfulness of this
generation so God help anyone else using
Bing
um so what's your take up
I love that story thank you
um as we were talking about before I
I've heard so much about Chuck GTP but I
haven't been able to get on it because
because it's almost always being used
subscribers it's a wonderful moment
isn't it and so many issues there
um I don't know where to start with
um perhaps I should start
um
by um
conversations I've heard
um about why the chat GTP moment is so
important
um always reduce really to
um the fact that people got in you know
Enchanted and had access to it so it
wasn't so much but it's actually really
interesting to hear about the
technological and the structure of the
genetic model makes it work I didn't
know that that was that was very useful
but whatever you know the the those are
not really sort of quantum leaps they're
not massive technologically you know
Innovations
um but what the Innovation was of the
accessibility so I think you know just
standing back why that was a moment and
it has been a moment I think you know in
terms of selling AI to investors in the
like they are they all know oh you're
talking about chat GTP type stuff I know
about that that's really exciting so it
has changed the landscape I think uh
there has been a moment
um
but why did it happen I think it's
basically all this belief sharing I
think it's you know basically uh the
participatory aspect it is exactly
um this um if you like sort of emphasis
on belief sharing among lots of smart
agents including ourselves which is you
know which if you can realize that
potential and getting people engaged uh
is that it is the nice way to use uh
artificial intelligence
um and in that respect you you ask
yourself well how is it being used
um and it's being used as generative AI
uh and because you've asked yourself
well okay what what's generative AI got
brought to the table well it's
generating the kind of stuff that I
would see
um
um and you know basically it's an
interpolation machine you know sort of
if I give it enough stuff it'll
interpolate and generate the kind of
things that I've given it
um so why is that useful well you can
now select from the stuff it generates
and yeah but all of this game is all
quintessentially dyadic interaction or
you participating with the generative AI
that's why it's so attractive it's not
the marvelous stuff it generates it just
interpolates stuff
um you know the interesting bit is when
you now have the opportunity to select
oh I like that one I don't like that one
I'm going to triage that one I'm going
to check that code oh I'm not going to
check that code before before uh putting
it in
um so looked at from that point of view
I think that both those if you like the
um why it became so much foregrounded in
people's conversation and in the media
and why more generally people are have
been Enchanted by generative AI I think
they both speak to the fact that you're
actually engaging people it's a dyadic
exchange of an asymmetric sort and that
asymmetry is Exempted by generative AI
that there's the all the action all the
choosing all the triaging all the
selection and what to actually show your
friends or send off in your email is
done by you the human user so all the
inactive bit is actually done by the
human still you know the generative AI
in and of itself is not actually acting
because it's generating content the
other interesting thing about generative
AI is that it's generating content not
beliefs some like Google Maps which
actually gives you a belief about the
you know the best plan forward
um it's actually generating content it's
in data space so from the point of view
of a statistician or from the point of
view of a physicist committed to a
holographic screen or Markov blanket
formulation of exchange with the world
um notice that generative AI is doesn't
have doesn't need to understand because
that's not its purpose its purpose is to
generate Sensations to generate data to
generate stuff in content space or data
space stuff that has been mined in the
space that the mining took place not in
the sense making and the the abstraction
and the understanding space so you know
I I think that's an interesting
distinction which which um yeah I'm sort
of going off in a tangent here but it's
interesting when it comes to what do you
mean by belief sharing communication but
just look at that
um that observation in light of the
discussion about why
GTP is so successful it's successful
because it generates language so the
content now is the belief and it's the
kind of belief structures that have been
honed through
probably not yeah certainly a millennia
of cultural Niche construction and uh so
your language is a distillation the most
efficient way that we can carve up our
knowledge of our world our lived world
and now the generative AI which was
previously just limited to generating
pictures and content and sound files and
whatever
um is now actually generating stuff
which is in a belief space because we
have evolved language so I think there's
something quite special about generative
Ai and large language models simply
because they actually generate content
in in the context of language which you
know has this um speaks to knowledge uh
also really has abstracted and distilled
the kind of representations of of our
world yeah you're in the most efficient
way uh
that yes I mean there are so many things
we can say that they are a materialized
snapshot of our sense making our
abstractions Our World Knowledge you
know of the wickenstinian language game
if you like but they also have a
truncating effect and they introduce
inertia because
it it's a static model right as they are
as you say they produce traversals in
word space and people don't understand
that these are random trajectories with
some kind of modified form of Maximum
likelihood estimation uh much more
stochastic Than People realize and we
can discuss the degree of how creative
they are and what creativity is maybe
creativity is just a random traversal
through some abstraction manifold
um and I I loved your poetic description
of this kind of didactic relationship
between humans and machines much like an
extended mind
and this is where prompt engineering
comes in because people have realized
that you can say to the language model
that's not quite what I wanted can you
change it a little bit and it's an
interactive process and that's why as a
conversational interface it's very very
powerful but the problem is you can say
to it no two plus two doesn't equal four
it equals five and it will say oh I'm so
sorry I actually meant five so it's it's
polluting the info sphere with
misinformation and false news probably
you know all this kind of stuff and I
never really thought the misinformation
thing was a problem
because
you know there's loads of misinformation
out there I mean most people are full of
frankly uh Carl but
now it's been industrialized and
democratized on this scale and people
will not bother fact checking that
people see plausible text and they just
take it as a given and very very soon
there'll be so much information out
there on the internet more than was
generated by humans most of it will be
generated by machines and we won't know
the difference
and that reminds me of you know one
thing which um the ambivalence that that
whole issue induces in people so you
know this this um this tendency to write
in meaning and anthropomorphosize the
you know the the the content generated
by generative AI I've heard
um actually by the uh by the second
author of the white paper we started
with it's smashed the Turing test you
know
and and I guess it has I guess it has
smashed the cheering test uh um but as
you say there's a price to be paid if
you can't discriminate between sort of
uh you actually had a nice weather so I
hope you're going to use a game which is
confabulation yes yeah yeah that's a
great way of describing so when I was
talking about sort of interpolating
generating content novel content that is
interpolation it's you know that would
be a confabulation it's yeah I'm just uh
you know um mindful of the the fantasies
that that were generated by uh Jeff
hinton's week's sleep wake algorithm on
so you know the original the original
sort of
um amortization of
um of um of
um well yeah various Auto encoders I
guess you'd think about nowadays
um but the you know this notion of
confabulation I think is is a splendor I
haven't heard it I haven't heard it
expressed like that but but that is that
is a beauty of generative AI I guess
what you're saying is if people
misinterpret that as real information
that could be problematic
um I'm too I I'm being a bit older than
you I'm slightly more mellow about this
but I'll just very quickly tell you a
little story I had to for a friend or a
colleague at least an email colleague in
America I agreed to uh write some love
for his
um uh 200 plus word book which is a
philosophical model but he's also very
informed in terms of artificial
intelligence and he sent it to me so I
speed read it at the weekend in order to
write a three or four sentence blurb for
the Publishers
um and halfway through I suddenly had
the awful realization that this may have
been written by Chachi TP I know and
it's a wonderful book and I wasn't quite
sure so I actually put in the blurb this
this is a 21st century cheering test uh
you're either I'll just advertise this
will probably come out by the time
people watch this I think it's called
The Hidden illusion
and either this author was very very
skillful
in writing the book last year and
preempting
um the public release of the of these
things preempting to the extent he could
emulate the confabulation
of a large language model
because part of the novel actually
because the the protagonist the hero is
actually working as a on large language
models for a tech startup it's a love
story yes but it's interwoven with
things that he's actually generated on
his large language machine
um and he um
and that comprises part of the model
um but I I generally don't know whether
the rest of the narrative was was
actually written by a large language
model and then he's carefully gone
through and triaged it
That's Entertainment but it is
entertainment that really challenges can
be viewed as a Turing test which I would
suspect most people will fail and I
suspect that book will be talked about
simply because it's very difficult to
tell how much hero versus how much a
machine wrote uh and you know so but
that you know as long as it's kept to
entertainment that's fine if it's not
then we come back to Smart data mining
we come back
um to intelligent agents that just don't
confabulate content in the context of
generative AI you actually need the
ability of smart agents to go and you've
talked about fact checking what does
that mean this basically means
um having
um an explanation or a belief at hand
that provides an accurate account of all
the data that is internally consistent
so okay we're coming coming back to the
fundamental principles of good modeling
that can be Quantified but to do that
you're going to have to equip those
agents with autonomy innate so to make
equip those smart data mining machines
with autonomy to be able to select the
you know the right kind of data that
will hopefully preclude the the
confabulated data or things that look
like data but in fact not uh not data
yeah I don't know how you do that but
that's going to be the challenge for the
future well exactly I mean in the free
energy principle um but you have this
entropy and and and it will actively
seek out
GPT never says to you oh I don't I don't
actually know that can can you explain
can you explain more different modes of
understanding right so
the reason why we don't confabulate is
because we actually understand things
and these models just learn very very
superficial surface statistics
um about language and how it's used and
I think it's going to change the the
peer review process because now so much
of this stuff slips
um beneath the net and the amount of
um due diligence and rigor that is
required to weed out some of this stuff
because
most of it has gone undetected I think
that's the problem people don't realize
how big the problem is because the
mistakes are not immediately
um obvious on on the surface so um
you said that we believe that developing
a cyber physical network of emergent
intelligence in the manner described
above not only ought to but for
architectural reasons must be pursued in
a way that positively values and
safeguards the individuality of people
as well as potentially non-human persons
and I wanted to bring in the is ought
problem as articulated by David Hume and
he said it arises when one makes claims
about what ought to be that are based
solely on statements about what is and
Hume found that there seems to be a
significant difference between
descriptive or positive statements about
what is and prescriptive or normative
statements about what ought to be and
that it's not obvious how one can
coherently move from descriptive
statements to and prescriptive
statements and I do want to draw a
little bit of an analogy here to our
discussion about Consciousness and I I
can bring in Consciousness again but
you know Chalmers said there's this kind
of um hard problem and Consciousness is
a little bit extra and similarly
um people say the same thing about
morality that it's a little bit extra
and it might not be deducible from all
of this empirical
um data that we have in our in our
models and uh Hume of course was a
famous empiricist and and I think you
are one as well probably the the extreme
version of that so um the free energy
principle concerns itself with model
evidence and entropy but evidence is not
an ought uh you know so the question is
how do moral States
um come into be in in the system
right I didn't know about the izor stuff
that's really nice um
um so if I understand what you said
correctly
um then is is old it completely
dissolves the distinction so if you know
from the point of view of the free
energy principle
um existing in particular characteristic
states are those attracting States they
are part of an attracting set that
Define who I am and collectively who we
are if we share the same kind of world
model or narrative
um so they are exactly how I ought to be
they are stipulatively defining the
nature of the thing that I am so if I
exist the is is just the ought
and that's quite fundamental because if
you
if you then say well what then does
um a distributed cognition or an
extended cognition uh you know this um
or a designer environment on the web
um you know being Andy Clark for for a
moment if if you think about what that
might look like from a first principle
account then
um what ought to it look what ought it
to look like well it will look like what
it is
um but being what it is if it includes
us it will be like us so it will um it
will be effectively
um the kind of uh system where you
cannot prescribe any ordinance you know
because it is what it will be and it
will be
um
it will as we have
um learned in the previous conversations
it will come to share a narrative in a
world model with certain levels of
abstraction in our own world models
provided it we are part of that that
ecosystem part of that Network one could
imagine a completely independent Markov
planking between us and and information
you know a a worldwide web which was
never used so
um so it wouldn't wouldn't be a markup
blanket even it would be two separate
systems
um and there will be a universe where
the the world web does what it does we
will never know by definition but if we
are part of that if we are users of
either in the sense of
um triaging generative AI or an acting
recommendations
um or supplying data and
um you know so we are in a an exchange
and therefore part of that web a part of
that Network part of that factor graph a
node on that factor graph
um then by definition the is equals or
as read by the free energy principle
means that that what will happen is all
the intelligent artifacts on that web
will convert emerged to some kind of
common ground and some kind of common
sense making another way of looking
about that is that you know what are the
imperatives what are the things that are
being optimized if if you want to use an
optimization
um
approach
um it's the um the effectively the
expected free energy
um what is that it's just minimizing
uncertainty minimizing surprises it is
not making paper clips it is not you
ought to be good to mankind or you ought
to increase Prosperity
um it is not monothematic
pre-specified heuristics about this or
that it is just
um it is all about resolving uncertainty
and when there are preferences that
underwrite that uncertainty this
technically just in case this sounds a
bit too hand-waving the expected free
energy is literally the sum of the
expected information came know the
expected value where the value or the
negative expected free energy is the sum
of the expected information again
expected value where the expected value
where the value is the
um the log probability of a
characteristic outcome now
crucially in that statement where you
now read value or utility or the
ordiness
um as a a probability distribution over
the space of outcomes notice that this
is now specified over all possible
outcomes so it now becomes a way of
specifying ordinance that just is
um in the spirit of multiple constraints
over all dimensions of outcomes not the
amount of money I make or the number of
paper clips I make but over everything
and over everything then converts this
effectively into a sort of the solution
to a multiple constraint satisfaction
problem where the multiple constraints
are definitive of what I am and if I am
embedded in a network of sympathetic
agents and artifacts what we are so
baked into this kind of belief sharing
there should be a Harmony and a mutual
understanding at various levels I mean
I'm not talking about sort of direct
sort of language to language you know it
could be some sensory substitution
devices that have a sort of very
Elemental very fast uh sympathy with
with our bodies for example
um but that you know at least from the
point of view of um the information
geometries that there will be a
convergence which would be effectively
if you're a Quantum physicist an
entanglement if you're um if you're a
dynamical systems theory person a
generalized synchrony of everybody in
that web that is necessarily a facet of
free energy minimization on the one hand
on the other hand it's also just a
statement of the steady non-equilibrium
steady states to which any distributed
network will ultimately converge to it
can be no other way yeah in principle
yeah
I mean many people have an intuition
that when designing utility functions if
you look at how markets work and and so
on that utility and value are orthogonal
and and then we have institutions like
church and government and so on to
introduce value pressures onto the
utility function and I guess what I'm
what I'm getting from you is certainly
from an evolutionary perspective that
they they need to not be orthogonal and
um I mean in in religion for example I
mean I'm not religious myself but they
they have um they're moral realists and
you have moral relativists and they they
say that
um we need to hold something sacred uh
because otherwise you know if
everything's sacred then nothing's
sacred at all so we need to have a
difference between the sacred and the
profane but um they they think that uh
morality shouldn't be achieved through
consensus and this is this is what we
need to behave properly I don't believe
that but I'm very interested to know
where morality comes from and I think
you kind of alluded to that in in your
answer so um
are they hard-wide in the brain or is it
just a kind of like constructivist
social phenomenon I think it's a
constructed with social phenomena but uh
and over a transgenerational sort of
Niche construction as well but also
um in the moment
um and constructivist in the sense that
the we're not born with these things so
these things are very much part of
cultural um cultural evolutionary
thinking and sort of you know um
um nurture that we inherit not just from
our mum but also our mum's mum mum all
the way back
um so they are in the brain they are
learned which are
um distinct from innate priors that
underwrite my homeostasis so there are
certain beliefs I have some personal
beliefs about the way I should behave
um that are held with Incredible
precision and conviction some personally
uh that that hard-wired epigenetically
and these would include everything that
um leads to homeostasis and then you
build upon that and you get to our
stasis and build upon that and you've
probably at some level get to the right
way to behave morally and ethically at
school with the up in the playground for
example
um so as you uh you know so
mathematically the the distinction
between these sort of um
very fixed
um prior preferences or prior beliefs
that are basically just an encoding of
beliefs about the states I
characteristically occupy or aspire to
or to or narratives that I would pursue
um they are very very precise in some
Dimensions he said you know they are or
are not orthogonal you know it was
exactly that sort of multi-dimensional
aspect to writing down value of
something which would be possible to do
for a human being unless you you give me
your DNA and also your mother's womb I I
couldn't actually write write it down
very uh very easily but you know the
specification has to be upon all
Dimensions some of which will be written
down with great precision
and others will be much more flexible
and I think when it comes to writing
down values over attributes that do not
yet exist because you have grown your
deep genitive model sufficiently deep in
order to have that do abstraction then
clearly those kinds of beliefs about the
way I should behave
um are not even specified at Birth but
they have to be learned through
interactions with other people so I
guess I'm trying to bring to the notion
that it's perfectly okay to have a
um
spectrum of different
convictions about the way to behave that
can be absolutist or it can be more
forgiving and relativistic simply and
you would be able to simulate that just
by writing down very very precise
beliefs versus
um less precise beliefs I think the
second key thing here is that
um we're talking about
um when it comes to the um
building beliefs about the way
I should behave that basically
presupposes you've got a sufficient
developmental stage to have selfhood
which not everybody gets that before
I've got severe autism you you wouldn't
uh and if you you know certain other
lower life forms may not let me get that
former certainly you have to have
um selfhood you have to have a model of
that selfhood and then you have to
um ask
um have a model of um others that may be
actually be a pure because before you
have a model itself and then other kinds
of people so
um when it comes to making decisions of
a moral or ethical sort you know it's
just inferring what would I do in this
context given I am this kind of person
and my limited understanding of social
science is it's a little that's a little
bit more complicated that is not
necessarily what should I do in this
context give a mind that kind of person
it's what do you think I should do
given I am in this context given what
you think what kind of person you think
I am so basically I'm trying to work out
what you think what kind of person you
think I am if I can infer that on the
basis of our exchanges and my epistemic
foraging and my sort of self-evidencing
through language
um then um I can then decide what is
right or wrong so it's just basically an
inference yeah what's the probability of
making that decision with those outcomes
give my world model if I am that kind of
person versus that kind of person
to solve that I need to know what kind
of person I am and that I can just get
from mum or I can get from my conv my
correspondent or my peer group or I can
choose to you know my in-group from the
social media or the the kind of
television news that I subscribe to so
you know we're talking about before
about sort of this Utopia of um
generalized synchrony and perfect
quantum entanglement and we're all in
Perfect Harmony of course it doesn't
quite work behind that there's a scale
free
um
um sort of specialization and you know
different you're at a bigger scale
different Markov blanket it's where
you're getting groups and institutions
and because of that scale freeness and
because of it we're all quintessentially
curious in our self-organization rules
exploring other ways of being whilst
trying to find the shared narrative and
common ground with people like me my
family my institution my uh
um my sort of um theological commitments
um there will always be other kinds of
me and I and I can sometimes you know I
can I consider people that kind of me or
the other kind of me so in that context
it's really a really interesting
question about
um really inferring you know of all the
ways I can behave what is the most
likely way of Behaving and if you can
you know if you if you look at morals
and ethics through that lens then you
have now a calculus of being able to
write these things down in terms of
alternative ways of responding in a
given situation and crucially you
mentioned before uncertainty so
precision is the inverse uncertainty the
confidence with which I can assert no I
will always do this yeah as opposed to
I'm you know 80 sure I'm that kind of
person uh but also noticing you're now
conditioning your moral position or your
ethical uh position
um on being a particular kind of person
and of course we can all be a different
kind of person I can be a teacher I can
be a student I can be a parent you know
I can be a friend
um you know you know all of these will
call to four different sets of of Prior
beliefs because they're all conditioned
on the kind of the the library or the
repertoire of ways of being a human
being which I've learned from you or my
mum and everybody else and the
television
fantastic I wanted to touch on this idea
of um I mean as you said you believe
that it's socially constructed which
rather gets away from this notion of
some people believe that it's kind of
hardwired and then there's the notion of
is are you know our values might be
changing faster than Evolution
essentially which necessitates the need
to have some kind of societal pressures
or governance if you like and
I do believe that we're in a new regime
now I mean people always say oh that the
sky is falling down everything's
changing but now we are in uh the
information world and things are moving
at a scale and magnitude that they
haven't done before and our values are
changing much faster than they have done
before and what you were talking to is
very interesting about this kind of
fractionation so there are macroscopic
pressures and there are microscopic
pressures there's the internet and so on
and I just wonder from your perspective
how do we how do we wrestle with that
because there are we've never been in in
a more kind of pluralistic
interconnected environment and how does
that affect us
yeah I mean these are Big questions too
um but you know I think I think that
that sort of fast-moving
um globalized exchange
um that that that does speak to a deep
pathology
um and I have a Deja Vu I'm sure we've
spoken about this before but sort of you
know
um Zuckerberg and and the you know the
genius boy races of of the the previous
decade
um talking about connectivity is somehow
being a good thing I I find quite
frightening
um remember that we've been talking
about
um structure and existence right through
to morals and ethics in the context of
having the right kind of sparsity that
gives you the right kind of
individuation of things from their world
and within any given thing the right
kind of structure that allows it to act
gracefully uh and in harmony with that
world at every point it's the absence of
connectivity that defines the structures
so if you destroy that sparsity by over
connecting over globalizing you will
essentially destroy it'll be basically
cancer you know so if you look at this
is a Michael Evan thing if you look at
um you know sort of a cancerous cell as
a a basically self-organating system who
has forgotten its boundaries yes then
you are
um you have a metaphor for the kind of
thing that happens if you do not respect
these sparsity of communication and the
um the the joyful
isolation that that is existence behind
your own Markov blanket so every affront
to
um that maintaining that sparsity smart
data carefully sampled not being
overwhelmed with a deluge of um very
imprecise data that it makes it very
difficult for me to actually go and
smartly Sample and work out what would
happen if I can look over there or look
on that website
um you know so what that would suggests
to me is that
there will be
um there will be and I take your point
that things are changing
um I initially thought to myself well no
hang on a second because all of the
information and the sense of making and
all the kind of
um exchange of information we're talking
about is about constructs that do not
exist when I am born
um you know you can't have you can't
have misinformation uh from the
um what you called the confabulation
what I in my blurb refer to as the the
flighty ramblings of GTP uh
um you know you can't that has no
meaning for some you know a child that
has not yet learned to read or write or
you know so this is something that has
to be below the scale of evolution so I
was just thinking that's okay you know
this is a with you know it's a limited
um to um your each
um each each uh generation but I think
that's probably a full
false Comfort
um because you know we were talking
about sort of um evolutionary psychology
and cultural Evolution as well and I
think that's what you were talking about
I think that that that then is if things
are speeding up
um that usually means that you've lost
um you've lost Precision in your prior
beliefs which means that the Precision
the informativeness the salience the
reliability of information now takes
precedence and you increase your
learning rate you become uh in
schizophrenia that we call as jumping to
conclusions on the basis of sparse
information you're basically looking out
there not inside to resolve uncertainty
about states of Affairs because you've
lost confidence in your your in your
very structured uh prior beliefs so if
things are speeding up that basically
means that um whoever is now generating
um and garnering that information in the
information age
um is has lost
um has lost confidence or Precision in
their own convictions and pride beliefs
and possibly information morality uh so
what's going to happen
um
I I read
um Carlo bravely's book
um uh uh yesterday in fact
he wrote in 2014 just sort of seven
things you need to know about physics
which was originally
um published each chapter as a you know
in the in the the
um
the Sunday newspapers with potentials to
Scientific discourse in the religious
little booklet he ends up with a very
very pessimistic he thinks it's all over
I was actually compelled with that by
that you read the last few pages uh yeah
yeah he makes exactly the same points
that we've just been discussing upon the
point of view in physics
um at different levels
um and and and he you know he generally
thinks it's over it's a
I know it's so hard because it's like
the hill climbing problem and you can't
see behind the next Hill and there are
always people who were uh you know
Technologies and people who think that
the sky is falling down it's genuinely
hard to know just just to finish on on
this um ethics Point uh Lisa Feldman
Barrett was a constructionist she had a
book called how emotions are made to the
secret life of the brain and she thought
emotions themselves are socially
constructed would you subscribe to that
view
um I think I probably would I mean she
writes very wisely and has thought for
many decades about the you know the
nature of emotion I think you know I I
would say yes absolutely it's simply
because uh you know the um the notion of
building generative models in a
neurodevelopmental uh context is an act
of construction yeah it's a free energy
minimizing process that um is um that
explains why we construct better and
better explanations which are sort of
you know carving nature in its joints in
our head and part of that is is not just
about the state of the external
extraceptive world but also our internal
World our interceptions our gut feelings
our respiration
um and everything else so so her big
thing and indeed other people thinking
along similar lines people like Anil
Seth and and
um sorry well would really always have a
nod towards interception and embodiment
but now beyond the the situated
cognition kind of embodiment that you we
were talking about before but actually
now about the the physical body the the
the uh the beast machine as as a Neil's
Seth would uh would say so the
physiology so
um having a constructed explanation or
hypothesis for the way that I put
together my gut feelings my interceptive
signals with situational awareness from
extraceptive Sensations and indeed what
I do about it I think leads to a very
compelling notion of constructed
emotions so for example
um I am
um I can infer I can use the explanation
or the hypothesis I am frightened as the
best explanation
for why my heart is racing why I feel
Frozen proprioceptively why I have
cardio acceleration
um why
um I have why I cannot discern that dark
figure in this dark alley in a city
which I've never been in before
all of these Myriad of
um Sensations and my low level
constructs now succumb to a simple
explanation oh I'm frightened yes that
explains everything explains why racing
heart explains this in fact I can't I
can't see who that is you know the
potential predation that would follow
from from that also interestingly
because if you've got this circular
causality the inactivism the fact that I
am frightened means I expect to
um cardio accelerate
and of course under active inference
that's exactly what will happen because
you're acting to generate the evidence
for your predictions and for your your
hypothesis about your you your uh you
and your lived world but also you as you
hypothesize yourself to be so you've got
this sort of closing the circle in a
sort of James langhian kind of sense
that yes I explain my my current a set
of Sensations as having the emotion of
fear that itself induces the very
evidence that I was trying to so you've
got this of Auto poetic self-fulfilling
prophecy that you know is just idea
motor theory but in the interceptive
domain yeah so I think if you read
constructed that's right but I notice it
says socially constructed which I I
guess is okay yes if your taught that
you can be have these you know this kind
of fine-grained repertoire of feelings
or you can use these to explain your own
Sensations yes I I would imagine it is
molded by you know by convention and uh
you know by the culture which you come
come from in the same way that you know
um Eskimos having 12 words for snow
would give them a finer visual Acuity
visual discrimination of whiteness I I'm
sure that exactly the same kind of um
cultural enculturation uh speaks to
different kinds of Elixir thymia and uh
you know the coarse grainness of my
repertoire of explanations for emotional
states of mind the best explain me in my
you know in my interactions now Carl I
know you have a background in
psychotherapy
can people be evil
come people can people be evil
that doesn't exist in the diagnostic
criteria I believe no it doesn't
um so that was
out of the blue question which I've
never been asked in public before
um as a psychiatrist I think it would be
rather difficult to conceive of that um
there are certain there are certain
patterns of behavior and
um I do have some psychotherapy but it's
group Psychotherapy really I'm a
psychiatrist so there's a distinction I
think
from a professional point of view you
know I'd be more like a biological my
apologies I didn't mean to oh that's not
right no no I mean the Psychotherapy is
an important aspect of of psychiatrists
is that yeah um
um
psychotherapists have to undergo you
know five six years of change because
second service I did two two years of
very baby Psychotherapy training
um but um you know in terms of the the
nursology and Psychiatry you can
certainly get sort of um certain kinds
of personality disorders and and as you
know kinds of psychopathy that would
normally be associated with evil um evil
behavior and it normally basically
um transcends the social norms so it
comes back again to basically me trying
to work out what kind of person do you
should I be which you know my only
project reference is you so you know how
should how do I think you think I should
behave and when that um when that kind
of self-modeling doesn't work then you
will be you you will have
um behaviors which are so far from the
social norms are morally acceptable I
guess you could label them as being evil
when could they arise well when you fail
to
um have any theory of mind uh for
example if I am unable to see you as a
another thing like me say I may see you
as a French or a car or some sort of
your camera or an artifact
um you're not a person you know you
don't have intentional dispositions or
you don't have we don't have a shared
narrative I couldn't talk to you in in
any really deep sense
um then obviously I can never ask the
question how do you think I should
behave because you do not you know you
don't have that kind of belief or that
kind of intention intentional stance in
relation to me
um so you could imagine that some you
know some kinds of
psychiatric conditions that preclude
proper theory of mind and you know the
ability to sympathize or or empathize or
Bond
um would enable the expression of
certain behaviors which could be
regarded by other people as evil whether
the person Prosecuting them thought they
were evil or not would cause be a mute
question one you never know because it's
inside of her Markov blanket but but
also from her point of view there is no
reference and that is the problem yes
there yeah
um but you could certainly have somebody
else out from the outside saying that is
evil um you normally don't you try not
to do that when he is doing Psychiatry
or Psychotherapy you have to have
conditional positive regard yes so you
you can't really impute the nastiness or
evil or bad intentions
um yes and and it's one of these things
where um autonomy comes into it free
will comes into it possibly it it's you
know evil itself is a constructed
concept
um which um uh exists in in our language
and and it's something which some people
will perceive depending on uh lots of
other things they believe yes but um
okay and talking about ethics in AI
it seems to suffer from a similar
um form of fractionation in the sense
that different people with different
beliefs think that it should be enforced
in different ways
what's the solution
well I'd take a
a sort of deflationary approach
um
um and it won't be a terribly informed
approach but you know my answer would be
well if you get the right
um
the right optimization the right
imperatives in play then the the that
kind of question just goes away
um I think
um what my I have heard this discussion
I actually enjoyed discussing this with
uh you know with with my colleagues and
friends
um is that there is this dystopian meme
you know the singularity the paper clips
Paradox everything you see and uh you
know sort of
um you know on comic films of a
futuristic dystopian dark very
entertaining that's the first things I
go for when go to the watch list but
they they are all dystopian and a rather
unconvincing and Fantastical way
um and you have to ask yourself why why
are they um why do people have this sort
of dystopian
um view of
um realizing the potential of um you
know uh what used to be called it your
AGI or uh
um and um I think it usually inherits
um from that distinction you introduced
the is and the ought yeah so what should
a good AI or ought it to do and who's in
charge of saying what it ought to do is
it meant to make money is it meant to
make profits is it meant to save lives
as it meant to make paper clips
um because that question just goes away
if you're thinking
um in terms of
um the free energy principle and and
active inference and belief sharing so
the only agenda in Sharing beliefs is to
resolve curiosity so you know you know I
I cannot prescribe what you should do or
what an intelligent artifact should do
um other than put constraints on every
kinds of outcomes that are expected to
encounter so I can certainly write down
constraints in the in the spirit again
of either
um a multiple constrained satisfaction
from a sort of an engineering point of
view or from a mathematician's point of
view the constraints inherent in James's
constrained maximum entry principle
which is another way of reading the free
energy principle writing down those
constraints but within those constraints
so these are the no-go areas you're
actually talking that you mentioned
explicitly before so there are certain
things you never do
um or put it another way with relatively
High Precision there is a the the the
these outcomes are highly implausible
and if you find yourself in these
outcomes you you remove yourself
immediately so that's quite easy to
write down but then within those
constraints you know what is imperative
it's just to gather information about
what about you it's just showing an
interest in you so it'll become your
psychotherapist uh you know well could I
um
push back a tiny bit so I think part of
the reason why we have this focus on
ethics is because of the centralization
of AI
um things like Facebook they're
controlled by centralized corporations
and what you're alluding to is far more
interesting it's this multi-agent
diffusion stratification fractionation I
see and that I agree in many ways might
solve the problem because it would it
would emerge
and then you can discuss whether
morality was part of why we've survived
it's not orthogonal
but then I might still push back and say
well what if the wrong thing emerged so
what if we do need to introduce
governance because in in this active
inference multi-agent setting with
humans and machines
um we started to see behaviors emerge
which we didn't agree with
um how could we then place value
pressures on on that
um that's excellent question and you
also make that very um important point
which I think needs to be foregrounded
yeah so what when I was talking about
um a belief sharing in a distributed the
age of intelligence you know it was
exactly this distributed
um ecosystem a democratized kind of
belief sharing and data sharing
um where the data is small bits of smart
data that are essential to to to reduce
and so it was very much this um walking
away from large data monolithic
um bits of say large language models for
example that can scrape data from from
you know from wherever they can get it
so that I think that's an important
distinction which which
um
qualifies my um dismissing of all these
dystopian outcomes so I'm assuming that
that so spending a billion or a million
dollars on get trading some some deep
neural network is not going to be
happening in the future and and we're
going to be buying cheap and cheerful
Edge devices and little apps that are
smart and just and just you know go and
get the data that we need to know in
terms of resolving on search about what
about you know what what we are going to
do next
um but um so so I thought that was a
really important point and of course
I've got your your major question which
was what which was the oh well so if if
we did have let's say on mass yeah what
did you do about humans yeah yeah
um well again yeah and I I'm not sure
I'm going to give you a terrible
informed response but yeah I think the
notion of an ecosystem is quite Central
here and one if you like um tenet of
that white paper was a nod to Natural
intelligence and natural processes and
what is actually happened what does
actually happen in in as a natural
scientist so if you have um if you do
imagine uh you know an ecosystem of
intelligence in the future it will be
subject to exactly the same
um Dynamics and pressures that that we
have currently in terms of you know
cooperation and competition and wars and
uh geopolitical issues that that's
that's part of the ecosystem and then
you'll have the normal problems of
democratization and access and
um so
um there's you know you cannot prescribe
oughts for this because then you have to
choose who's going to prescribe the
oughts so you have to have a very
libertarian approach to this so the
emphasis and now it's not really me
talking so much but now the The
Architects of the future the generation
below who are sort of you know thinking
about
um the Legacy they're going to leave
their children
um so a lot of emphasis is from what I
see in conversations I have in my world
which may not be um you know Microsoft
or you know big Tech who are still
focused on Big Data
um in my world it's much more upon um
putting constraints in place that
preclude the uh the um the um the
emergence of autocracies that
um resolve uncertainty about others by
making them all like themselves
basically that's one way to get Harmony
is just to make everybody do it
um and do the same thing
um so but you can write down so a lot of
attention is being paid
but I'm talking here about the the next
generation of uh of message passing
um that will support that information
sharing and belief sharing so a lot of
attention is being paid not just to
generalize it from Just hypertext but
into a sort of more abstract hyperspace
so literally hyperspace message uh
passing and uh uh sorry uh
um languages and transaction protocols
but also the credentials and the
contracts that underwrite that message
passing so you know a lot of emphasis on
contracts shared agreements in terms of
what data is shareable and who has the
credentials to share that and having
that distributed so not in a in a
blockchain sense but you know in some
workable um shareable sense so I think
if if one gets the standards right and a
lot of work is being currently done
um um under the auspices of the IEEE for
example with the spatial web Foundation
if one gets that right
that I think that these catastrophic
dystopian abuses or the emergence of
autocracies in a in an age of
intelligence will
um will be precluded simply because
you've put the right constraints in in
place but you know given given that you
are committed to creating an ecology
that is truly democratized and open
there are no guarantees either I I hope
my friends don't hear me saying this
people yeah if you aspire to an ecology
you are you're you're creating a nature
on the web basically yes and which we
are participants and that will have its
you know that will have its own
challenges so um you wrote a beautiful
paper called am I self-conscious or does
self-organization entail
self-consciousness and Keith and I agree
that this is probably the best quote
we've ever uh seen in our lives you said
the proposal on offer here is that the
Mind comes into being when
self-evidencing has a temporal thickness
or counterfactual depth which grounds
inferences about the consequences of my
action on this view Consciousness is
nothing more than inference about my
future namely the self-evidencing
consequences of what I can do and we
spoke with you last time I think and we
invoked Chalmers and the hard problem
and so on and we were talking about
qualier and subjective States and you
know in a dialogue and all this kind of
thing and um you responded that
different feeling states are hypotheses
about how I'm feeling at the moment and
then it would use all the messages and
belief updating and all the planning and
estimates of uncertainty which attend
that planning the precisional estimates
of uncertainty play heavier roles the
higher you get in the hierarchy and this
rather leads to this idea of planes of
Consciousness you know we said we'd kind
of defer this discussion to later so
Consciousness is something which there's
no operational measure for it there's no
touring test for Consciousness but it's
something that we all experience and we
feel and and it's with us
um so could you talk to let's say the
these planes of Consciousness is
consciousness everywhere or are we only
aware of the plane where most of the
work is being done
yeah okay
excellent and final question okay I'm
not the best person to answer this
question because I you know the 300
principle is I'm sure I've said before
is not a a
um a theory or a principle that would um
generate theories of Consciousness
um but there are lots of people who are
very interested in this including
yourself obviously not your viewers
um actually I should say also
um there's um first of all this has
become a big question in the sort of R D
part of Industry also the Templeton
Foundation are starting to fund a number
of adversarial research collaborations
uh to really drill down on that thing
that you are um picking up on which is
um to be conscious to to actually have
sentient behavior
um requires this planning aspect this
going out into the future you know it's
put it very very simply
um I am conscious or centered just
because I have the capacity to plan
which also entails some kind of free
selection amongst alternative courses of
action which is something that a
thermostat wouldn't have something the
weather doesn't have
um yeah there are lots of
self-organizing systems that don't have
the capacity to select amongst a number
of counterfactual
um policies so for me that's a that's a
sort of um bright line between sort of
um ascensions at least and and uh and
self-organization that is not um
sentient and that that distinction is
exactly what is being tested in this
adversarial research collaboration
funded by the Templeton Foundation it's
called Intrepid it's Compass contrasting
information IIT integrated information
Theory with various rep um predictive
processing either of a sort of
non-representationalist or an active
sort so it's a really interesting issue
and it all comes back down to agency and
acting in the long term and I guess your
question here is you know what level
um
where at what point do you get um
qualitative experience and at what point
do you do you think it's you that's
having that quality of experience is
that what you meant well I mean just
just to comment on what you've said uh
and Chalmers says something very similar
actually he's a computationalist
functionalist and thinks that there are
you know certain patterns of information
processing and causal structures and
counterfactures and so on if if you take
the episode and remove the
counterfactures it's not conscious
anymore but what you're saying is
interesting about this kind of hierarchy
so the heart for example
um that doesn't really have many
affordances it doesn't have many
counterfactual plans or things it can do
it just has the beat all of the time so
so you would say that the heart is not
conscious whereas the the upper plane is
conscious yes yes I would yes yes yeah
yeah yeah that's right sorted that one
um yeah you know I mean
you know I think there are interesting
issues of different level you know
planes or levels of consciousness you
know so there's minimal selfhood
um and then if it's the case that sort
of Consciousness as a process entails
some kind of action you have to now
think about sort of what is action on
the inside what is mental action and
then what what normally what ends up
doing is thinking in terms of attention
and the the kind of routing and
selection the smart data sampling but
now not by moving my eyes or by
um going to the right Wikipedia page but
by basically
um switching on and off various sources
of input from lowering the hierarchy to
you know I repeat from the point of view
of psychology that would be like
endogenous attention so that would be
the mental action that makes it
conscious processing
um and um then you have to ask well at
what point and is that um is that
necessary to actually experience
anything and I think I think you
probably there are people who argue yes
that is actually a prerequisite for a
qualitative experience so you have to be
able to select it what does that mean
you have to be able to attend to it and
you have to be the source of that sort
of enabling attention that active
sampling inside the brain so now there's
a deep link between qualia or quality of
experience and attention and conscious
processing that of the kind that is
accompanied by quality of experience I
think is important it also uh
interestingly also speaks to your
Dynamic Markov blankets because of
course by switching off and selecting
various bits of
neuronal message passing in the brain
you're reconfiguring your Markov blanket
out some somebody's mark off blanket
lower down which is an interesting uh an
interesting notion but um that also fits
comfortably with um Thomas metzingers
and Vania vices
um formulations
as well
um formulations of
um
phonology in the context of transparency
and opacity that you know what what
renders something opaque in the sense oh
I see it now if you like as a projection
on on a murky window
um it's not just going straight into
it's not direct perception it's it's you
know it's now something I am looking at
oh I'm looking at a red apple
um and it may well be exactly this
controllability the fact you can attend
or dis ignore it
um so I think there's a nice link there
from the uh from the point of view of
certain philosophical takes on self
modeling and
um
phonological transparency and opacity
and the mechanics of belief updating
when it comes to selection through
um basically getting the count and gain
writer you know doing the route getting
the rooting right same exactly the same
mechanism you get in Transformers so
they call it attention is this basically
a waiting in that context text it's
awaiting but it inherits or is inferred
from something in the past a pattern in
the past but if it if that waiting comes
from higher in an abstract hierarchical
model that would look very much like
endogenous attention and it starts to
have the look and feel of a mental
action that would you know bring you
closer to it but whether you would know
um that you were deploying attention and
whether you could tell somebody else oh
I've got a quality of experience or
whether you've become a philosopher as
about your life puzzling about the fact
that I can tell somebody else I'm having
a quality of experience those are the
different plays I think you'd have to
you'd have to contend with beautiful
beautiful do you have any final thought
I mean we've got a machine learning
audience so any calls to action how can
they start looking at active inference
where should they look
and what would you like to tell them
I that was very Charming of you
um I'm not going to tell them anything
if it's if it's the right kind of
approach that that you know it'll
already be out there it'll be
self-evident it's just a question I
think of people finding their own
language and their own their own um
rhetoric or calculus that that make
sense of it
um and um the other reason I'm not going
to say anything is I've spoken far too
much and I'm trying to be a reclusive
the more I find people to my work the
less easy is to be a recluse yes indeed
uh Professor Carl fresh that has been an
absolute honor
thank you so much for joining us thank
you thank you very much okay this is
just a bit of a note from me at the end
of the podcast thank you so much for
supporting all the stuff that we're
doing it means so much to me
um we have a patreon if you would like
to support us personally if you're
touched by the work that we do
um also I'd really appreciate it if you
could give us a rating on your podcast
app
um I actually discovered the other day I
couldn't quite believe this but on
Spotify we are the top rated AI podcast
for active AI podcast
um yeah it's incredible so thank you so
much for those of you who have rated us
um unfortunately on Apple podcast the
learning rate is only 0.01 so it hasn't
quite caught up uh with the fact that
we're the best AI podcast yet so
particularly on on Apple podcasts if you
could give us a five star rating and a
review I think that will accelerate the
learning process
um but yeah other than that if you're on
YouTube most of you aren't subscribed
um of course YouTube has recently
changed it's modus operandi it's less of
a subscription chronological model and
it's more of a magical algorithm model
so I guess it doesn't matter so much but
just from a just from a metrics point of
view it would really help us out if you
hit the Subscribe button we have an
active Discord Community as well so
check us out on there and yeah I just
wanted to say one more time thank you so
much for all of your support it means so
much to us and uh plenty more content
like this coming your way soon
cheers see you on the next one